HEARING OF THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEES WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATE
TORS ND EMPLOYEES. WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
HOLDING HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. IN THE SENATE CHAMBER
WITH ME ARE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EVAN LOW CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. LET'S SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOLLY. SENATOR ARCH
ALETTA AND UNDOUBTEDLY MORE TO
COME WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF OPTOMETRY
IN THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY. AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASKED THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM OR HERE ON THE FLOOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD INDICATE TO ME BY RAISING
YOUR HAND THEN YOUR MICROPHONE
THAT WOULD HELP. EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR IT
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME.
AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING ROOMS IN THE SENATE
GALLERY TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISK
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
944-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR
ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING PUBLIC COMMENT
MAY BE PROVIDED UPON THE
CONCLUSION OF OUR PANELS
PRESENTATIONS AND FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
IN OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIST AND
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ATTIMES
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE UN MUTED. AND YOU WILL
NOW BE READY AND THEN BE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR.
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY HERE. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. SO TO ALL PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL. AND PLEASE BE
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES MAY BE HEARD. SUNSET
REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARINGS LIKE
TODAY'S ALLOW FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND EFFICIENCY OF
REGULATORY PROGRAMS. AND TO
DETERMINE WHETHER CHANGES IN
THE LAW. OR IN THE OPERATIONS
OR FUNCTIONS. ARE NECESSARY. WE
WILL BE REVIEWING SPECIFIC
ISSUES REGARDING THE
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA THE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY AND BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY TODAY.
TO ASSIST IN THE REVIEW AND
EVALUATION OF EACH AGENCY. ARE
SUPERB COMMITTEE STAFF THE
PREPARED BACKGROUND PAPERS
WHICH IDENTIFY ISSUES AND MAKE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EACH
PROGRAM. THESE PAPERS HAVE BEEN
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITES AND MADE AVAILABLE TO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES. EACH
PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE A VERY
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRAM
FUNCTIONS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES WILL THEN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR ISSUES WHICH THEY
MAY HAVE. WE WILL ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
CONSUMER GROUPS PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. FOR EACH PARTICULAR
PORTION OF TODAY'S HEARING. AT
THIS POINT I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE MY COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EVAN LOW CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE TO MAKE
ANY OPENING REMARKS THAT HE
DESIRES TO MAKE. SURE LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE ALSO
LOOK FOR TO THE DIALOGUE AHEAD
OF US. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU DO TO
HELP US WITH THIS PROCESS.
BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH OUR
SPEAKERS ARE LIKE TO INVITE
THOSE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WISH TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN
NOW. PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE
THE ACCESS CODE. SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE ONE. TO
BEGIN OUR PROCESS TODAY WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM DOCTOR SERVICE
BIHARI. PRESIDENT OF THE
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA WELCOME DOCTOR.
EURON. YOU SEE ME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THANK YOU TO THE
HONORABLE CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM DR CYRUS
BIHARI NEWLY ELECTED PRESIDENT
OF THE OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA I HAVE BEEN
A LICENSED PHYSICIAN AND
SURGEON PER PROXIMALLY
SEVENTEEN YEARS I ATTENDED
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL SCHOOL AT
WESTERN UNIVERSITY COLLEGE OF
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICINE OF THE
PACIFIC IN POMONA CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY I'M A PRACTICING
INTERVENTIONAL CARDIOLOGISTS. I
WAS APPOINTED TO THE BOARD IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND THE
SERVER AS SECRETARY TREASURER
OF THE BOARD FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS. I AM BUSY SEEING
PATIENTS IN MY OFFICE AND IN
THE HOSPITAL ON A DAILY BASIS
BUT I DO MAKE TIME. FOR THE
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD
BUSINESS BECAUSE I AND THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE BORDER
DEDICATED TO THE BOARD'S
PRIMARY MISSION OF PUBLIC
PROTECTION- TODAY FOR YOU TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT COMMITMENT.
THE BOARD'S MISSION IS TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC BY REQUIRING
COMPETENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
INTEGRITY IN THE SAFE PRACTICE
OF MEDICINE BY OSTEOPATHIC
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS. TO
ACCOMPLISH ITS MISSION THE
BOARD INVESTIGATES CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS AND CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS. RESPONSE TO
EMERGING CHANGES AND TRENDS IN
THE OSTEOPATHIC HEALTHCARE
PROFESSION LEGISLATIVELY OR
THROUGH REGULATIONS. VIDEOS ARE
FULLY LICENSED PHYSICIANS WHO
PRACTICED IN EVERY MEDICAL
SPECIALTY. DEOS PRACTICE A
WHOLE PERSON APPROACH TO
MEDICINE FOCUSED ON LOOKING
BEYOND SYMPTOMS TO UNDERSTAND
HOW LIFESTYLE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
FACTORS IMPACT WELL BEING.
VIDEO PROFESSIONALS ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING SEGMENTS OF
HEALTHCARE WITH ONE OUT OF
EVERY FOUR MEDICAL STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL
SCHOOL. THE NUMBER OF DEALS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED FROM
APPROXIMATELY. NINE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED SIX TO TWELVE
THOUSAND SIXTY EIGHT CENTS THIS
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SUNSET
REVIEW. THIS REPRESENTS A 31%
INCREASE IN THE LICENSEE
POPULATION. THE AUTOMATIC
MEDICAL BORDERS A SMALL PROGRAM
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
WE TAKE PRIDE IN FULFILLING THE
BOARD'S MISSION OF PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC. WE HOLD OUR
LICENSEES TO A HIGH STANDARD
AND TAKE SWIFT APPROPRIATE
ACTION WHEN NECESSARY. WE
CONSISTENTLY SETTLED CASES AT
OR ABOVE THE DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES. THE OSTEOPATHIC%
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IS
IN SUPPORT OF CONTINUED
LICENSING ORIGINAL IT
REGULATION BY THE CURRENT O. M.
D. C. MEMBERSHIP. THE- MBC IS A
GROWING PROFESSION WITH A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO MEDICINE
THEN THE MD COUNTERPARTS.
ADDITIONALLY AS AN INITIATIVE
CREATED BOARD WITH SPECIFIC
LAWS ABOUT THE STAB WISHING
GOVERN THE BOARD YES THE
PADDOCK MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA HAS SOLE AUTHORITY
TO REGULATE DEOS IN CALIFORNIA.
CONSIDERING THE GROWING
PROFESSION AND A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO MEDICINE DEOS
SHOULD BE LICENSED AND
REGULATED BY THE OSTEOPATHIC
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. I
WILL DO MY BEST TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS TODAY TO THE BEST OF
MY ABILITY. AND AT THIS TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE THE
BOARD'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
DOUG MISTER MARQUITA. MISTREAT-
YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU TO THE HONOR
ROLL CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARKET-
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD
SINCE JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN I'M EXCITED TO BE HERE
TO REPRESENT THE BOARD TODAY.
MY VISION FOR THE BORDERS TO
CONTINUE TO FULFILL THE MISSION
OF PROTECTING THE PUBLIC- THE-
PRACTICE OF OSTEOPATHIC
MEDICINE IS A GROWING
PROFESSION I'M EXCITED TO SEE
THIS CONTENT CONTINUE MOVING
FORWARD. THE BOARD DOES NOT
HAVE ANY ISSUES FROM A BUDGET
PERSPECTIVE OUR BUDGET IS
STRUCTURALLY BALANCED IN OUR
REVENUE AND EXPENDITURES ARE
FAIRLY CONSISTENT WITH EACH
OTHER THEREFORE THE BOARD WILL
NOT NEED TO PROCEED WITH A FEE
INCREASE FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE. ADDITIONALLY SINCE OUR
OUR BUDGET IS STRUCTURALLY
SOUND THE BOARD WAS ABLE TO
ABSORB THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
RATE INCREASES WITH OUR
EXISTING RESOURCES. SINCE THE
LAST SUNSET REVIEW THE BOARD.
REGULATES A NEW LICENSE TYPE
THE POSTGRADUATE TRAINING
LICENSE. BOARD INITIALLY HAD
CONCERNS OVER THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL BUT
FULLY SUPPORTS THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION TENSION OF THE BILL.
ADDITIONALLY THE BOARD HASBEEN
MADE MADE AWARE OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE. ARISEN AS A RESULT
OF THE BILL- BUT WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT ANY CHANGES TO
THE LOG- MAY UNDERMINE CONSUMER
PROTECTION. KOPEN NINETEEN IS
CREATED AN UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION FOR THE BOARD. OUR
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN ENSURING THAT
OUR NEEDS ARE MET. WITH THEIR
OPEN COMMUNICATION AND
GUIDANCE- THERE BEEN SEVERAL
WAIVERS ISSUE TO ENSURE THAT
KOBE DID NOT CREATE A BARRIER
FOR LICENSURE. ON THE BOARDS
AND- WE IMPLEMENTED
TELEWORKING. A STAFFER TATIAN
SCHEDULES AND- STAFFERDECENT
SCHEDULES AND ROTATIONAL-
OFFICER VISITS TO ENSURE THAT
THE CLOVER NINETEEN PROTOCOLS
WERE MET ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT'S I. T. TEAM WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN ENSURING THAT
ALL OF MY STAFF HAD ACCESS TO
THE NETWORK REMOTELY- SO
TELEWORKING WAS- SEAMLESS. I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY- AND AT
THIS TIME WILL TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU- MISTREAT- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEES. FOR THE PANELISTS
ON THIS PARTICULAR BOARD. LET
ME JUST ASK A COUPLE. PERHAPS
ONE OF YOU COULD TO COULD.
REVIEW FOR ME ANY ISSUES THAT
YOU SEE YOU ARE EXPERIENCING IT
AGAIN IF ANY WITH THE POST
GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE. I'LL
GO AHEAD ASK MARK TO TRY FAIL
THIS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS A GREAT QUESTION SO
THERE THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
ISSUES THAT HAVE ARISEN AS A
RESULT OF THE POST GRADUATE
TRAINING LICENSE- WE ACTUALLY
HAVEN'T RECEIVED THAT MANY OF
THE COMPLAINTS I'M AWARE OF ON
THERE'S THE MOON LIGHTING
ISSUE- WITH- WITH. DOCTORS
WORKING OUTSIDE OF THE PROGRAM
AND RECEIVING AUTHORIZATION-
FROM THEIR PROGRAM DIRECTOR-
THERE'S THE ISSUE OF OBTAINING-
THE D. A. AXE- CERTIFICATE. AS
WELL- BUT- WE ACTUALLY HAVEN'T
RECEIVED TOO MANY OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS AT AT- AT THE
AUSTIN. I THINK MEDICAL BOARD
ISSUES WITH- WITH THE POST
GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE WITH
MORE EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REQUIRED THIRTY SIX MONTHS OF.
RESIDENCY IS THE OUT OF STATE
LICENSE HE'S COVERED AND FOR
THEIR- FOR THEIR FELLOWSHIP IN
NEEDING TO HAVE THEIR LICENSE.
TYPICALLY ON JULY FIRST WHICH
IS ALMOST. A DAY OR TWO AFTER
THEY GET THEIR THIRTY SIX
MONTHS IN IT AND BEING ABLE TO
ACTUALLY OBTAIN. THEIR
UNRESTRICTED LICENSE AT THAT
TIME. SO IT'S KINDA YOU SHOULD
BE SEEN BUT LIKE I SAID EARLIER
WE UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES THAT
THIS HAS CREATED BUT- WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND ANNE'S ANY CHANGE
THE LAW MAY UNDERMINE CONSUMER
PROTECTION. WELL I ASSUME THAT
THE ISSUE TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE DEOS FACE. RESIDENTS FACE-
ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
POST GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE
THEY'RE THE SAME TYPE OF ISSUES
THAT THOSE SUBJECT TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA-
WILL FACE ARE YOU IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD WITH RESPECT TO ANY
POTENTIAL. FIXES THAT ARE UNDER
DISCUSSION BECAUSE CERTAINLY
WE- IF WE EXPLORE AFFECTS- AND
APPLIED TO BOTH WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WORKS FOR BOTH. AND
WE'VE HAD SOME COMMUNICATION
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD- BUT
LIKE I MENTIONED WE HAVEN'T
RECEIVED TOO MANY COMPLAINTS
WAS NOT AN AVENUE LEAVES- FULLY
WENT DOWN AT THIS POINT BUT WE
WILL BE IN COMMUNICATION WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD. MOVING
FORWARD. WELL ONE MORE QUESTION
ON A DIFFERENT SUBJECT TO
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION I
NOTICED THAT THERE'S SOME. A
DISCUSSION IF NOT PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF CME HOURS
APPLICABLE TO THOSE SUBJECT TO.
REGULATION AND CONTROL BY YOUR
BOARD COULD YOU SORT OF EXPLAIN
THE RATIONALE FOR THAT AND- HOW
OF HOW THE PROCESS IS MOVING
ALONG. BY MARK ELLIS YOU TO
TEST SAY SOMETHING AND I MAYES
CHIME IN AFTERWARDS. YEAH THE
RATIONALE FOR THEIR REQUEST FOR
THE SEAMY REDUCTION- SO IT. THE
ONE HUNDRED HOURS EVERY TWO
YEARS AT THE BOARD REQUIRES
CURRENTLY- KIND OF CREATES A
BURDEN FOR LICENSEES THAT HAVE
SPECIALTIES AND SUBSPECIALTIES
BECAUSE THOSE THOSE SPECIALTIES
AND SUBSPECIALTIES THIS PACIFIC
C. MEANS THAT THEY NEED TO.
COMPLETE FOR THE SPECIALTIES-
SO IT KIND OF CRAZY BURDEN FOR
THOSE LICENSEES AND IT AN
ADDITIONALLY ONE ALIGN RCB'S
WITH THE MDC WHO ALSO HAVE THE
SPECIALTIES. IN TRYING TO MAKE
IT INEQUITABLE SITUATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MAY ALSO ADD
SOMETHING THAT- I AGREE WITH
WHAT MARK SAID THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC BROUGHT TO
LIGHT SOME OF THE BURDENS
PLACED ON THE LICENSEES
REGARDING CME REGULATIONS- WE
HAVE CURRENTLY DOUBLE THE CME
REQUIRED BY THE INDY COLLEAGUES
AND THAT- WITH THIS PANDEMIC
PROVIDED I JUST PRESSED TO SEEK
INPUT GET INFORMATION FROM THE
STAKEHOLDERS. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT PROPOSED REDUCTION
DOES NOT HURT THE OVERALL
PARAMOUNT. MISSION OF THE BOARD
WHICH I PROTECTION OF THE
PUBLIC ALL OF THE CREDENTIALING
BODIES FROM THE HOSPITALS WE
WORK AT FOR TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND PROVIDERS THAT WE
HAVE TO BE CERTIFIED BY. HAVE
THEIR OWN CME REQUIREMENTS
ADDITIONALLY TO ENSURE THAT
PHYSICIANS ARE KEEPING. WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE. OF THE MOST
CURRENT. EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE IN MEDICINE. WELL IT
SORT OF MAKES SENSE TO ME OF IF
IT'S WHAT THE BUT THE CME
REQUIRED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA THAT YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS. ONE THING THAT
WAS NOT CLEAR TO ME FROM THE
BACKGROUND PAPER AND DOCTOR
PERHAPS YOU CAN- COVER THIS
FROM YOUR OWN PERSPECTIVE AS AN
INTERVENTIONIST GIG
INTERVENTIONAL CARDIOLOGISTS IN
TERMS OF THE SPECIALTIES WHAT
TYPE OF CME HOURS ARE REQUIRED
AND I UNDERSTAND IT PROBABLY
VARIES FROM SPECIALTY TO
SPECIALTY BUT IN YOUR OWN CASE
FOR EXAMPLE- IT THAT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION THANK YOU MR
CHAIR SO. FOR ME AS AN
INTERVENTIONAL CARDIOLOGISTS I
HAVE TO MAINTAIN AND A GENERAL
CARDIOLOGISTS I MAINTAIN
CERTIFICATION AND- ECHO
CARTOGRAPHY RADIOLOGY- ALL OF
WHICH REQUIRE SPECIFIC CME IS-
TO CONTINUE THAT CERTIFICATION
ALSO. AN ADULT CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE AND INTERVENTIONAL
CARDIOLOGY. THOSE THOSE CMA'S
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO MAINTAIN
THAT CERTIFICATION ARE NOT
NECESSARILY SEPARATE THAN THE
CURRENT REQUIREMENT DURING
CORPORATION TO THE CURRENT
REQUIREMENT BUT INTENTIONALLY
OSTEOPATHS- MAINTAIN. A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF CMES THAT THEY HAVE
TO GET EVERY YEAR THAT ARE
APPROVED BY THE AMERICAN
OSTEOPATHIC ASSOCIATION AS WELL
SO. WITH THE CURRENT LEVEL OF
CME REQUIREMENTS IT'S QUITE A
BIT OF- OF EDUCATION IN
ADDITION TO WHAT WE DO ON A
DAILY BASIS WHICH IS LEARN NEW
THINGS AND SORT OF ADAPT TO THE
WAY EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
BUT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE- SEPARATE SETS. OF
CME'S IN DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
OF EDUCATION WITHIN OUR
SPECIALTIES AND SUBSPECIALTIES
THAT WERE REQUIRED TO GET EVERY
EVERY SO OFTEN IN ADDITION TO
THIS. THANK THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE OF COLLEAGUES ON THE
FURNACE THE CENTER ARCHULETA.
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE PRESIDENT-
FIRST OFF I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
AND CONGRATULATE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD FOR BEING THERE FOR US
ALL IN THE GENERAL PUBLIC
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND ALL OF
US OF- IT KNOWLEDGE THE FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THE COURTS TO
DOCTORS AND NURSES WE THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AND INTENSIVE
TRAINING THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST- POINT OUT I'M I'M
IMPRESSED WITH YOUR MISSION
STATEMENT. WHICH IS SHORT SWEET
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR READY
PROJECT THE PUBLIC BY REQUIRING
COMPETENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
INTEGRITYIN THE SAFE PRACTICE
OF MEDICINE AND- IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE DOING
BUT YOU HAD MENTIONED THAT YOU
HAD AN INCREASED BY THIRTY
THREE PERCENT- EARLY IN YOUR
STATEMENT. WHAT DO YOU
ATTRIBUTE THAT TO. AMANDA
PASSING SO- SOME OF THIS
QUESTION TO MARK I'M NOT SURE
EXACTLY WHAT IT SHOULD BE TO
THERE ARE LOTS. MORE OUT OF
STATE LICENSING. SEEKING WHAT.
AND CAL- MAYBE PERHAPS BECAUSE
UPPER- IN THE CARE FOR. IT IS
MORE RIGHT THAN THE STATE
ADDITIONALLY WITH THE PANDEMIC.
MORE PEOPLE AND- SOUGHT
LICENSURE. GRADUATES FROM OTHER
MEDICAL SCHOOLS- ARE COMING
HERE. MAYBE MARKY CAN ALSO ADD
SOMETHING. I THINK THE GROWING
POPULATION I THINK- DR HARI CAN
HIT ON THE HEAD WITHOUT WITHOUT
A STATE LICENSE HE'S COMING IN
BUT IT ISN'T THAT. I THINK IS
THE POPULARITY OF THE
OSTEOPATHIC PROFESSION
PROFESSION IS GROWING THERE'S A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO MEDICINE
AND I THINK IT'S- IS GAINING
POPULARITY AS A WHOLE. YOU FOR
THE YEAR JOB YOU'VE DONE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND- IN
THE MEDICAL FIELD. THANK YOU
MR. ALEX ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THOSE ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
SEEING NONE I SEE NONE FROM
THOSE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GERMAN I THINK YOU CAN
CONSIDER IT TO BE A TESTAMENT
TO GOOD WORK THAT WERE NOT
LINED UP ASKING YOU A SERIES
OF. FAIRLY DETAILED AND
OCCASIONALLY HEARD QUESTIONS SO
THAT'S A GOOD THING. WILL NOW
ACCEPT TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY AND
THERE ARE NONE. LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. AND THERE ARE NONE.
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS IF ANY
WAITING TO PROVIDE. PUBLIC
COMMENT ABOUT THE OSTEOPATHIC
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. YEAH THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MEMBERS I SEE NONE
THAT THIS WILL CONCLUDE OUR
PORTION OF THE HEARING
REGARDING THE OSTEOPATHIC
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. WE
WILL NOW BEGIN A REVIEW OF THE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY AND WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME. MISTER MARK
PARDON BOARD PRESIDENT BUSH TO
MORE DUMMY.
MR MORE OKAY HI.
SORRY PLUG MYSELF THAT'S OKAY
LOOKING GOOD THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
ALL RIGHT WE CAN HEAR YOU
PERFECTLY THANK YOU MY
APOLOGIES- GOOD MORNING SHERRY
ROSS SURE LOW VICE CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE JOINT SUNSET
OVERSIGHT. THANK YOU FOR THIS
TIME TO ADDRESS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY IS
CONSUMER PROTECTION WORKING THE
LAST FOUR YEARS. MY NAME IS
MARK MORE TELL ME I'VE BEEN A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD SINCE APRIL
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND CURRENTLY
SERVING MY SECOND TERM AS
PRESIDENT. I AM NOT AN
OPTOMETRIST. IN FACT I AM THE
SECOND OF TWO CONSECUTIVE
PUBLIC MEMBERS ELECTED AS
PRESIDENT. I THINK- ARE
LECTIONS F. AS PUBLIC MEMBERS
THE MOST POWERFUL POSITION ON
THE BOARD IS A SYMBOLIC MESSAGE
B OUR BOARD BOTH PUBLIC AND
PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS. THAT THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY OF THE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY IS
PROTECTION OF CONSUMERS. WITH
ME TODAY ARE EXACT IS OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SHARP
PERKINS MURPHY. THE BOARD
HIGHER MISS MURPHY IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND SHE AND I WANT
YOUR QUESTIONS TODAY. SINCE THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN OVERSIGHT
HEARING THE OPTOMETRY BROUGHT
HAS ACCOMPLISHED A LOT. WE'VE
MADE SAFE I CARE AVAILABLE TO
MORE PEOPLE OF THE STATE. OUR
MAJOR VICTORIES HAVE BEEN A
RESULT OF THE CLOSE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. WORKING
CLOSELY WITH CARILLO THE BOARD
DRAFTED AND SUPPORTED ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETY SIX WHICH
ALLOWS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
OWNER OPERATE MOBILE OPT
OPTOMETRIC CLINICS. THESE
CLINICS WILL BRING I CARE
CALIFORNIANS WHO CAN LEAST
AFFORD IT AND LITTLE
PROFESSIONAL SERVICE DESK. I
PERSONALLY I'M MOST PROUD OF
THE BOARD SPONSORSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MAN IS VERY AND AB
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT AND TWENTY
NINE CLOSE. THAT LAW ALLOWS
OPTOMETRISTS MAKE HOUSE CALLS
HOMEBOUND SENIORS AND OTHER
HOME BUYING CALIFORNIA. MY AUNT
WHO IS IN HER LATE NIGHT IS THE
TIME INSPIRED BY PERSONAL PUSH
FOR THE LAW. THE QUALITY OF OUR
ELDERLY DETERIORATES WHEN
DECREASED VISION SKILLS THEIR
SMALL LIFE PRESSURES AND WE CAN
ONLY GET TO AN OPTOMETRIST'S
OFFICE WITH WITH INCREDIBLE
DIFFICULT WHEELCHAIRS. BANDS
THAT FEDERAL. I AM VERY PROUD
TO SAY THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC
THE BOARD IS BRINGING COMMON
STABLE PARTICULARLY THE STAFF.
FROM THEIR HOMES THEY'RE
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
THE BOARD STAFF PROCESS TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT GRADUATE
APPLICATIONS TIMELY DESPITE THE
PANDEMIC. WE HAVE TO HELP SIX
ABOUT PROXY SIX HUNDRED
PROFESSIONALS TO ENTER INTO THE
WORK FORCE DURING THE PANDEMIC
TO SERVE I HEALTH NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. AND FORCE IT
STRIVES TO REDUCE OUR CASE
BACKLOGS AFTER OF DESPITE THE
LOSS OF TWO SENIOR ENFORCEMENT
STAFF. ON A SEPARATE MATTER WE
ARE ENGAGING THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE AND STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
TO IMPROVE THE ENFORCEABILITY
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEJO'S
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY FOUR
AND ACT IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. TO
EFFECTIVELY PURSUE DISCIPLINARY
ACTION THE BOARD WILL NEED
STRONGER LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
ACT WHEN AN OPTICAL BUSINESS AS
UNDUE CONTROL OVER NOT
CONSCIOUS PACK PRACTICE. BUT
WITH THIS OVER YOU AYE THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS THAT
MIGHT ILLUSTRATE THE WORK OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY. THANK YOU MISTER
MOORE DEMI OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS.
CIARA MURPHY BOARD EXECUTIVE
OFFICER MISS MURPHY. OKAY HEAR
ME. GOOD MORNING ALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEVENTY TODAY AND DISCUSS THE
WORK OF THE BOARD- AS PRESIDENT
MORE DON'T YOU MENTIONED WE-
ARE SMALL BUT MIGHTY FORCE- AND
ARE WORKING TO KEEP OUR LIKE TO
THE TIMELINE BERNARD THANK YOU
COULD MOVING- AND HAVE HAD SOME
GREAT LAND OF THE LAST FOUR
YEARS AND BRING QUALITY EYE
CARE TO CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA- AND A QUICK ARE
OPEN TO ANY. QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
CORRECT ANSWER TODAY. PERFECT
MEMBERS EARLIER QUESTIONS FROM
THE FLOOR FOR OUR PANELISTS
CENTER ARCHULETA YES I THANK
YOU MEASURE- AGAIN I I'VE HEARD
WHEN YOU'RE FIRST OPENING
STATEMENT- MISTER PRESIDENT
THAT- YOU HAVE DOCTORS GOING TO
THE- SENIOR CENTERS AND- AND
SOME OF THESE HOMES WHERE
PEOPLE CAN'T LEAVE- COULD YOU
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT ON THAT
AND ALSO HOW SOME OF YOUR
MEMBERS MIGHT BE- WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE COMMUNITIES
AND OUTREACH IN SCHOOLS UNDER
PRIVILEGED AREAS. THAT THEY TO
NEED HELP- AS WELL AS OUR OUR
SENIORS IF YOU'RE DOING ANY OF
THAT COULD YOU ELABORATE ON
THAT PLEASE I'LL TRY TO I MEAN
A LITTLE BIT OF A OF A HISTORY
LESSON- IF YOU DON'T MIND.
BEFORE SOME OF THIS LEGISLATION
WAS PASSED- THE LAWS. TRULY
INHIBITED. THE LOS PROHIBITED
FOR EXAMPLE- OPTOMETRISTS YOU
MAKE HOUSE CALLS. LIKE OTHER
KIND OF HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS- THERE'S LOTS OF
AND LAWS PROHIBITED- ANY KIND
OF MOBILE CLINICS. SO BY
ENACTING- SHERMAN LOS
LEGISLATION THAT THAT KIND OF
ACTIVITY CAN CAN START UP AGAIN
COURSE YES THE HOMEBOUND
SENIORS THE HOUSE CALL
LEGISLATION WAS PASSED- JUST AS
THE PANDEMIC HIT IN FACT- WE
HAD OUR LAST HEARING LOSS
PUBLIC IN PERSON HEARING WHERE
CHAIRMAN LOW TESTIFIED- ADD. SO
WE CAN WORK ON HIS BILL AND
THEN THE PANDEMIC SO I HAD TO I
DOUBT VERY MUCH. ANY OF THAT
ACTIVITIES HAS BEEN HAPPENING
IN IN IN THE PAST IN THE PAST
YEAR. SURE CAN YOU ADD ANYTHING
TO THAT. IT CERTAINLY JUST THE
TICKET BACK SO- OPTOMETRY HAS
BEEN VERY MUCH PLACE BASED SO
THAT PRIOR TO- LEGISLATION IN
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS- I
PROMISES WERE ALLOWED TO
OPERATE ONLY ARM PRACTICES.
WILL USING A BRANCH OFFICE LIKE
THIS THAT- CERTIFIED- AND THEN
WE NW AND OPEN IT UP TO THAT
AUTHORITIES ARE ABLE TO
PRACTICE IN ELEVEN LOCATIONS
AND SURE SURE THOSE LIVING WITH
OTHER OPTOMETRISTS COMMENTED WE
ARE MOVING TOWARD MORE TOWARDS
THAT KIND OF COMMUNITY BASED-
TREATMENT THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AND-
CREDIT OR DOWNEY SAID IN BOTH
EIGHTY FIFTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT
EIGHT NINE SIX. GET A LOT. MORE
COMMUNITY BASED SERVER MODEL.
IF I CAN- OUR ANSWER TO YOU
SENATOR- AS A PUBLIC MEMBER
EVERY SINCE I JUST THE BOARD I
BEEN LOOKING AT OUR REGULATIONS
AT STATURE FREE IF THEY ARE
STATUTES THAT ARE IN THE WAY OF
GETTING HEALTH CARE TO THE
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA LAWS LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF OFFICES THAT
OPTOMETRISTS CAN CAN HAVE THE
LAWS AGAINST HOUSE CALLS LAWS
AGAINST MOBILE CLINICS SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FERRET THEM OUT AND
WE'RE ALWAYS OPEN TO
SUGGESTIONS AS TO HOW WE CAN.
INCREASE I HEALTH CARE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT I
HEALTHCARE WE'VE GOT CHILDREN
AND SENIORS YOU REALLY NEED THE
HELP SO AS WE OPEN UP
CALIFORNIA I'M HOPING THAT- THE
MEMBERS OF YOUR BOARD MEMBERS-
OF YOUR- ASSOCIATION. CAN GET
OUT THERE AND GET REALLY
PROACTIVE WITH THE COMMUNITY
THAT WOULD BE OUTSTANDING THANK
YOU MR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER TO A MEMBER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU CHAIR OFTEN ALSO TO
CHECK A LOW FAT CENTER
ARCHULETA JUST TO ALSO GIVE A
LITTLE TESTIMONY. OF THE GREAT
WORK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOCHER
LOW WITH THE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY- IN MY DISTRICT WE
HAD A NONPROFIT THAT TAKE THEIR
MOBILE- I CLINICS. TO A MIDDLE
SCHOOL. AND A FEW WEEKS LATER
THEY CAME BACK AND I
ACCOMPANIED THEM ON THE RETURN.
BECAUSE AFTER THEY TESTED THE
KIDS FOR FREE. THEY CAME BACK
WITH- I- I GLASSES. AND STARTED.
CALLING THE CLASSES OUT. THEY
WERE ABLE TO PUT A- A PAIR OF
GLASSES ON TO THIS LITTLE GIRL.
AND I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW
MOVING IT WAS WHEN THE FIRST
WORDS OUT OF HER MOUTH WAS I
CAN SEE. AND IT WAS THE MOST
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE SO THIS
IS HAPPENING IT'S WONDERFUL
THANK YOU CHAIR LOW FOR YOUR
GREAT WORK WITH THE BOARD AND-
JERRY ROSS. FOR THIS OVERSIGHT.
THANK YOU- NUMBER GRAYSON AND
WITH THAT CARILLO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU'RE OFTEN JUST TO
ECHO THOSE COMMENTS TO AS
IMMIGRATION HAS BEEN PIVOTAL
AND ALSO ADVOCATING ON THIS
ISSUE SPECIFICALLY IN THE
DISTRICT AND SING BEST
PRACTICES STATEWIDE SO KUDOS TO
YOU ALSO FOR HELPING TO ENSURE
THE MANY OF THESE DIFFERET
ISSUES- THEN DIRECTLY TO THE
BOARD MARTIN TRIES GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN IT WAS A PLEASURE TO
COME VISIT YOU AT YOUR BOARD
MEETING LAST. YEAR OR THE YEAR
BEFORE TIME FLIES- BUT IT'S
GREAT TO SEE YOU AND SILICON
VALLEY AT YOUR BOARD MEETING AS
WE DISCUSSED A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES SO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
BEING SO ACCESSIBLE THE FIRST
QUESTION IS WITH RESPECT
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES AS YOU
KNOW THAT WE HAVE HAD A NUMBER
OF DISCUSSIONS WITH RESPECT TO-
TELEHEALTH AND SPECIFICALLY
THAT OFCONSUMER PROTECTION
MAKING SURE THAT WE UTILIZE THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT EXIST BUT
ALSO PROTECTING ACCESS TO CARE.
AND ALSO THAT TO THE HARM OF
PATIENTS SPECIFICALLY IN THIS
AREA OF TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS
THAT ALLOW FOR PATIENTS TO
RECEIVE UPDATED PRESCRIPTIONS
FOR CONTACTS OR GLASSES WITHOUT
HAVING TO VISIT A LICENSEE AND
THOMAS TRYST DO WE KNOW OF ANY
POTENTIAL RISKS ARE HARM. TO
CONSUMERS SPECIFICALLY WITH
THIS TECHNOLOGY. LET ME START
TO TRY TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
AND THEN SHURIKEN- HOUSE MORE
OF A GROUND LEVEL OF
PERSPECTIVE- COURSE. IT IS THE
MISSION OF THE BOARD- PROTECT
CONSUMERS THINK AND INSTEAD OF
THE CARE CENTER OF KERRY IS THE
BOTTOM LINE. WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE FOR
A LONG TIME NOW WE HAD
MEETINGS. IN 201-929-2020 WE
HAD A TELEMEDICINE WORKGROUP
ACTIVE- AND OUR WORKGROUP
CONCLUSIONS ARE THAT I IN ANY
FOR DISCIPLINE STAKEHOLDERS AND
CONCLUSIONS ARE THAT. OPTOMETRY
IS GENERALLY NOT A FIELD THAT
LANDS THE TELEMEDICINE- BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
A LOT OF ONLINE RETAILERS-
DOING THE REFRACTIONS ETCETERA-
BASED ON- BASED ON APPS- WHEN
THIS FIRST HIT OR SCREENS. I
REMEMBER HEARING. COMMENTS BY
OPTOMETRISTS ASKING US TO. MAKE
THIS ILLEGAL- OUTRIGHT- OUR
IMMEDIATE ANSWERS USUALLY IT'S-
THE OPHTHALMOLOGIST THAT THESE.
PRESCRIPTIONS OR THESE
EXAMINATION GO DROPPED
OPHTHALMOLOGIST. AND SO WE HAD
NO JURISDICTION BUT IT IS A
GROWING MATTER- THE WORKGROUP
HAS TOLD US THAT- THAT ONLINE
REFRACTIONS- RECENTLY ACCURATE
CORRECTIVE LENS PRESCRIPTION.
BUT. CANNOT ACCESS THE- HEALTH
OF THE ICE PHOCION THE PATIENTS
I. A OR TREAT DISEASE- PROVIDE
CONSULTATION ON PATIENTS THIS
HEALTH SO- WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
CONTINUING TO STUDY IT IT- IT
IS A IT IS A CONSIDERABLE- IT
IS A DIFFICULT PROBLEM PROBLEM
FOR US TO CHECK DROPPED. TO
DRAW THE LINE THE RIGHT LINE
SURE SURE CAN YOU ADD TO THIS.
ABSOLUTELY NOT THANK YOU CHIRLA
FOR THE AT THE OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE THAT OBVIOUSLY WE- OF
COURSE GOVERNMENT CODE
PROHIBITS ME FROM- SPEAKING TO
TRIGGER THE COMPLAINT. BUT A
COURSE- EIGHT ENDED YOU CAN
LOOK RIDICULOUS TWENTY CATEGORY
THAT WE TRACK- THERE IS SOME
IMPORTANT ACTIVITY AROUND
HOUSTON BUT YOU INCLUDED
SERVICE MODEL- BUT AGAIN I
DON'T. KNOW THE SPECIFICS OF
THE SHARE THE SPECIFICS ABOUT
THE CAN'T HIT THERE HAS BEEN
PARTICULAR HARM- AND AGAIN AS
OPPOSITE. WARNED ONLY MENTIONED.
I FOR A LONG THE- SERVICE WILL
BE MODELED USE MY I
OPHTHALMOLOGY- VERIFYING THOSE
A BIG PUSH FOR- SO WE'RE ONLY
JUST TO SEE THAT. IN OPTOMETRY
AND WITH THE LEDGER OF. THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AS YOU
KNOW WE BELIEVE IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMPREHENSIVE EYE
EXAMS I COME FROM A FAMILY OF
TOM INTEREST. LAST YEAR WE WERE
TO BUILD SPECIFICALLY IN THAT
TO HELP EXPAND THROUGH A MOBILE
OFFICES AS AS IMMIGRATION ALSO-REFERENCED. AND I STILL THINK
IT'S A YET TO BE DETERMINED AND
NOT YET CONVINCED THAT
RESTRICTING THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES DO CAN- DO HAVE
DIRECT PATIENT HARM. AS WITH
THE CASE OF COURSE FOR US TO
ACT SWIFTLY IN THE AREA OF THE
ORTHODONTIST SPACE FOR EXAMPLE-
BUT WE SHOULD LOOK FOR POLICIES
THAT HELP ADDRESS MANY OF THESE
DIFFERENT ISSUES IN TERMS OF.
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY SO I KNOW
THAT YOU'LL BE ON THE FOREFRONT
OF THAT TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE
SUPPORT TECHNOLOGIESAND ALSO
CONSUMER PROTECTION AT THE SAME
TIME. THAT TRANSITIONING TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO- BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN THE BOARD
BEGAN DRAFTING LEGISLATION TO
IMPOSE NEW REGULATIONS ON
OPTICIANS AND OPTICAL COMPANIES
IN OUR STATE. I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE THIRTY OR SO STATES
THAT HAVE NO REGULATION IN. THE
OPTICAL SPACE BECAUSE OF THE
JOBS THEY PERFORM YEAH AND OR
WHETHER NOT THE PERSON SPECIFIC
RISK- INTO THE QUESTION IS HOW
DOES THE BOARD TO KNOW OF ANY
SPECIFIC RISK OF HARM TO.
CONSUMER PROTECTION THAT MAY
JUSTIFY. THE REGULATION IN THE
SPACE. SO YOU KNOW THE V. THE
OPTICIANS DO INTERACT WITH WITH
PATIENTS AND- THE PROBLEM
ARISES MOSTLY FROM FROM.
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE- AND COSTLY
FOR TO IS WHEN OUR OXYGEN
CROSSES THE LINE AND STARTS TO
GO OUTSIDE THEIR LANE AND TRIES
TO BE EIGHT OPTOMETRIST OR
OPHTHALMOLOGIST AND DIAGNOSING
OR GIVING HEALTH CARE ADVICE
RATHER THAN DOING THAT FITTING-
I THINK THE- THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE SO FAR IS REALLY
ADVANCED- CONSUMER PROTECTION-
RUBY GARCIA WHO IS A FORMER
MEMBER WHO WAS A MEMBER OF OUR
BOARD- WORKED VERY HARD TO-
COULD PROFESSIONAL ICE. THE
OPTICIAN PROFESSION TO OUR
BOARD WE'VE ENACTED
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES THAT
WOULD- RAISE THE STANDARD OF
ETHICS AND- AND PRACTICE- AND
WE'VE CONDUCTED ENFORCEMENT-
THAT. PRIOR WHEN THE OPTICIANS
WERE UNDER THE MEDICAL BOARD I
THINK- ENFORCEMENT AND-
ENFORCEMENT AND REGULATION OF
THE OPPOSITION'S WORSE ON A ON
A ANY- A LOWER PRIORITY SO I
THINK WE HAVE A CHANCE THE- THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION- SHERIFF.
THANK YOU FOR AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE FOR THE ORGANIC ON A IT
IS IMPORTANT RIGHT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE CARD DATA WHAT
WE HAVE R. B. CONFUSE CONSUMERS
THE LITTLE- COME BACK AND SAY
MY OPTOMETRIST GOT MINE MY
PRESCRIPTION WRONG WHEN IN FACT
IT- KNOWLEDGEABLE OXYGEN HAS
FILLED THAT PRESCRIPTION IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN DONE IN A WAY
THAT WOULD- GET OF WORK FOR THE
PATIENT AND ALWAYS REMEMBER ONE
OF THE STORIES TOLD TO ME BY-
TO CHALLENGE THE FORMER BOARD
MEMBER OF OURS- AND SHE WAS
PART OF A LARGER PRACTICE AND-
THERE WERE. OPPOSITION BUT
PEOPLE CAN DO WE OPPOSITION TO
WORK RIGHT- RETAIL WORKERS
REALLY AND TRULY WERE THERE TO
HELP LAST WEEK- BUT WE'RE DOING
OPPOSITION LIKE STAYING AND SO
WHEN THEY SIT. ADULT CLASSES.
THEY THEY WOULD PUT THAT MEET
UP. CUSTOMER'S IP OUT OF THE
WORLD AND THEN THERE WERE
ACTUALLY A AN INSTANCE WHERE. A
PATIENT CALL THE- AND SAID- I'M
HAVE A LOT OF AND- REALLY NOT.
WHEN WEARING GLASSES- AND THE
DOCTOR SAID WHAT YEAH COME ON
BACK IN YOU KNOW WHAT WON'T
WILL HAVE YOU KNOW THE ON. THE
TAKE A LOOK AT IT SPOKE I'M
ACTUALLY IN THE PARKING LOT.
AND I'VE BEEN TOLD TWICE NOW.
THAT I JUST NEED TO GET USED TO
IT- UNTIL. ALWAYS BEEN MY ME
THAT. IT A CLEAR CUT WAY US TO
LOOK AT IT GET THE DATA ON THE
ISSUE BUT I THINK THAT WHEN IT
GOES BAD WE KNOW THAT OFFICE IS
NOT TO BE TRADE BETTER SKILLS
ARE NEEDED WITHIN THE VISION
HERE SPACE- AND THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
REGULATED LEGISLATIVE OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE THEY'RE TRYING TO FIRE
BY CALIFORNIA'S LEGISLATURE TO
REGULATE THE PRACTICE. BUT ALSO
THEN TO FURTHER LOOK AT
SANDERS- DIVERSION SILICATE
CANTER- YOU KNOW BUT OVERSEEING
RETAIL WORKERS TO LOOK AT- YOU
KNOW EDUCATION AND EDUCATION
ALL OF THAT I THINK THAT WE
WANT TO SEE IT WE KNOW THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE THERE AND IT NEEDS
TO BE. PROVIDED WITH SKILLED
LABOR BECAUSE IT IS TOUGH TO
GET OUTSIDE OF ANECDOTAL BUT WE
HAVE SPENT TWENTY NINETEEN WITH
OUR PROFESSIONAL- FROM THE
OPPOSITION ON THE DIFFERENT THE
OPTICIAN COMMITTEE REALLY GOING
THROUGH THEIR EXPERIENCE- AND
THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF
SUPERVISING THOSE WHO ARE
RETAIL WORKERS AS OPPOSED TO
OPPOSITION I'M NOT A PERFECT
EXCELLENT REPORT IS A CONTACT
CENTER. I MEAN IT REALLY FOUND
THAT YOU KNOW THERE THERE IS A
NEED FOR THE KILL LEVEL- I'M
NOT TOO SURE TO BE ON THE FLOOR
AND COULD BE A PART OF THE
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE HOW
THE DOCTOR ARE SET. AND ADAPTED
FOR A CONSUMERS. BUT WHILE I
MAKE TO THE TO THE- COMMITTEES.
WE NOT WANT TO OVER. IN THIS
ERA. ONE BE VERY. MANY THE AT
THE- FIELD IS. A AND ENTRY JOB
IN THE AYE HEALTH INDUSTRY.
HELLO OF PEOPLE ONLY HIGH HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION- THEY DON'T
GET PAID VERY MUCH. SOME OF THE
MORE INSPIRING STORIES I'VE
HEARD MY WORK ARE. PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SERVED TIME IN PRISON AND
LEARN TO BE OPTICIANS IN
PRISON. AND NOW WANT TO HAVE A
NEW TART IN THEIR LIVES AND
WANT TO BECOME LICENSED
OPTICIANS- OF COURSE WE HAVE TO
REVIEW THEIR- THEIR-
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE OF THE
THERE ARE SERIOUS CRIMES THAT
THEY'VE COMMITTED. BUT THAT
THERE THERE THE DIGITAL FIRING
SPARRING STORIES ABOUT HOW THEY
WANTED TO MAKE AMENDS FOR THEIR
PAST WHETHER IN THEIR YOUTH OR-
YOUNG DECADES BEFORE. AND SO WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THESE PEOPLE
TO BECOME OPTICIANS AND NOT
OVER REGULATING AREA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR BOARD PRESIDENT
APPRECIATE HEARING DIRECTLY
THAT STATEMENT ABOUT NOT WHAT
DID THE DESIRE NOT TO OVER
REGULATE BUT ALSO. MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE A PULSE ON WHAT'S
GOING ON. WITH RESPECT TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT AND
FINALLY THE QUESTION ON FOR
MADE. IT IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER- YOU PROVIDED A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES THAT WAS
US OF CONCERN. ON THE
CLARIFICATION ON ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY. WAS VERY TROUBLED TO
READ IN THE BOARD SUNSET REPORT
ABOUT A IN MAJOR OPTICAL
RETAILER REFUSING TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW. NAKORN REPORTED
IT APPEARS THAT THERE'S A
COMPANY. THAT TO WHICH THE
BOARD HAS ISSUED A TOTAL OF
TWENTY ONE CITATIONS. AND YET.
THIS COMPANY HAS REFUSED TO
COME INTO COMPLIANCE IS THAT
ACCURATE. SINCE THIS IS A FORCE
THAT LATER I'LL TURN THIS OVER
TO THE EXECUTIVE OFFICE. YES
SIR LOW THAT IS ACCURATE WE
HAVE- CITED LOCATION TWENTY ONE
TIME- AND WE ARE STILL NOT ABLE
TO GET THAT LARGE RETAILER INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW. THE
UAE REPORT IT'S AT THE FOR THE
FINES ARE AN AMOUNT OF FOR THE
TOTAL OF ALL OF THE CITATIONS.
IN TOTALITY IS SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS- IT
HAS THE BOARD BEEN ABLE TO
COLLECT ON IN THOSE CITATIONS.
NO WE HAVE NOT HEARD. AND TO
DATE THE BOARD HAS SPENT ALMOST
A QUARTER OF A MILLION DOLLARS
ON INVESTIGATIONS AND LEGAL
DEFENSE OF THE CITATIONS IS
THAT CORRECT AS IT IS WITH THE
SITTING REPORT. THAT IS CORRECT
SIR. SO WE WILL- TO THE ROAD TO
BOARD EXACT OF OUR FOR OFFICER
WHAT WHAT'S WRONG HERE WHAT
TOOL DO YOU THINK IS MISSING
FROM- FOR US TO GET COMPLIANCE
BECAUSE IT JUST APPEARS THAT
THERE'S A BIG MIDDLE FINGER
THAT'S BEING. SENT TO US AND IT
IS POP BERMAN TROUBLING THAT
YOU'RE NOT EMPOWER TO HELP
ENFORCE THE LAW AT HAND SO WHAT
DO WE NEED TO DO TO HELP
EMPOWER YOU TO BE SUCCESSFUL ON
THE ISSUE OF ENFORCEMENT. OKAY
THEN- THE OUR REPORT WE HAVE
ENGAGED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
WITHIN THE STATE- UNFORTUNATELY
I DO NOT HAVE. LANGUAGE THAT I
CAN GET YOU RIGHT HERE AND
RIGHT NOW WE ARE STILL WORKING
THROUGH THAT- BUT- IT REALLY
ISN'T STRENGTHENING IN THE
TAXIS THAT THERE. MUST NOT BE
UNDER THE INFLUENCE. OF THE
OPTICAL COMPANY. OVER THE
TREATMENT OF PATIENTS
SCHEDULING APPOINTMENTS- THE
APPEARANCE THAT. THAT- I
POLITICS. THAT THE OPTICAL AT
PROVIDING- OPTOMETRIST WHEN IN
FACT THEY DO NOT AND CANNOT AND
SHOULD NOT BE I'M INVOLVED IN
THE INDEPENDENT WORK OF AN
OPTOMETRIST UNITY COLOCATED
WITH THEM- WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE I
AM PLEASED TO CREATE A- AWAY ON
THE LINE IT WAS HAD IT HERE THE-
FRONT OF. I WOULD THINK ABOUT
IT- BUT WE HAVE THE ENGAGE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS- DESIGNATED THE
CURRENTLY IN THE APPEAL
PROCESS- AND SO WE ARE GAINING
MORE KNOWLEDGE EVERY DAY- ON
HOW WE CAN STRENGTHEN- FIVE
FIVE. IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS ARE GIVEN THE WRONG
IMPRESSION ABOUT THE PROVIDING
THE SERVICES. AND OUR- BEING
PUSHED BY LOCKING THE POSTER AS
OPPOSED. TO GETTING
COMPREHENSIVE I. AND SO AS AS
AS WE ARE THIS. IN THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING THE BOARD IS
SICK LEAD TO. CLEAR FOR. AND
THORNY TO ENSURE THAT YOU. HAVE
THE- THE ISSUES. TO BE ABLE TO-
BUT THAT YOU HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO ENFORCE I SHOULD SAY. YES WE
ARE HERE AND WE HOPE THAT WE
CAN ON COMPUTERS WITH STAFF AND
THEN BRING THAT INFORMATION TO
MEMBERS BEFORE ARE BUILT ON A
PATH. WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY
CURRENTLY ON GETTING THAT
LANGUAGE TOGETHER FOR YOU I'M
AND I THINK THAT A- LOT OF HAVE
BEEN WALKING BY DOCTOR HOW THE
CONVERSATION. AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY BRING THAT LANGUAGE
ABOUT ANOTHER COURSE- WANT. TO
DETECT THAT WITH. NUMBERS THANK
YOU I JUST OF. READING YOUR
YOUR REPORT IN FISCAL YEAR.
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN. AND TWO
BUDGET YEARS THE BOARD
REQUESTED EMERGENCY BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS TO CONTINUE THE
LEGAL DEFENSE. SO THREE YEARS
IN THE MAKING. I'M READING-COURAGE YOU TO BRING THIS TO
OUR ATTENTION RATHER THAN WAIT
FOR AN OVERSIGHT HEARING FOR US
TO TACKLE THAT ISSUE. SHOULD
THERE BE ISSUES IN WITH A HAND
AND I OFTENTIMES KNOW THAT
THINGS TAKE TIME BUT- WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT WE SUPPORT GOOD
ACTORS. AND DOES THAT-
COMPLETELY ARE BLATANT IN THEIR
APPROACH TO NOT IN COMPLYING
WITH THE LAW WE WANT TO BE SURE
TO TACKLE THAT ACCORDINGLY.
THANK YOU SIR WE APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THAT OPENED UP AND I
CERTAINLY WILL WILL COME TO YOU
ON IRRESPONSIBLE IN THERE IF
THERE IS. THE SORT OF EREGIOUS
BREACH THAT INTEGRATING AT A
DISADVANTAGE. YES WE WANT TO
SET YOU UP FOR SUCCESS SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YES THANK YOU BYE
STATURE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHIRLA JUST A COUPLE FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS THEN ON THE QUESTIONS
POSED BY MY- COLLEAGUE THE
CHAIR- IN THE AREA OF
TELEHEALTH IF THE- APPLICATION
OF TELEHEALTH FOR RICK
REFRACTIVE SERVICES CONTINUES.
I'M JUST CURIOUS FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE BOARD WHAT'S
THE APPROPRIATE INTERVAL THEN.
FOR COMPREHENSIVE EYE EXAMS. IS
IT ONE YEAR IS IT TWO YEARS.
THREE YEARS IS THERE ANY
AGREEMENT ON WHAT SUCH AN
INTERVAL WOULD LOOK LIKE. AS
OUR CARD WE DISCUSSED EARLIER
WE AREN'T PUT TOGETHER TO LOOK
HELLA HELLA HELP WORKING GROUP
THAT HAD BEEN- DISCUSSING THESE
ISSUES AND BRINGING IT RESEARCH
FROM OTHER STATES I WE HAVE NOT
COME DOWN WITH IT AND IT IS.
INTERNAL BUT I THINK THE OLD
PEOPLE LOOKING AT ABOUT TWO TO
THREE YEARS UNLESS OF COURSE
THERE IS A MAGNIFIED NOT
MEDICAL ISSUE THAT REQUIRES
MORE FREQUENT CHECKING OF ONE
PRESCRIPTION BECAUSE AGAIN THAT
IS. BEST CELEBRATED THE BORDER
FROM DOWN TO BUT AS WE HAVE OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR TELEHEALTH
HEALTH WORKGROUP- WE ARE SEEING
THAT INTERVAL B. USED IN OTHER
PLACES BECAUSE I ASSUME
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER WE'RE
HAVING A TELEHEALTH
CONVERSATION OR A COVER
CONVERSATION ABOUT. I HEALTH IN
GENERAL THERE MUST BE SOME
GENERAL AGREEMENT. IN THE
PROFESSION AS TO HOW OFTEN-
SOMEONE SHE AT. GO IN FOR A
COVERING AG SO I UNDERSTAND.
THAT YOU'RE SO IT'S TWO TO
THREE YEARS IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
FOR US AS WE- WORK THROUGH THAT
ISSUE- HERE AS WELL SO KEEP US
POSTED ON THE RESULTS OF THAT
COMMITTEE IF YOU WILL. AND THEN
ON THE ISSUES RAISED BY CHAIR
LOW HAVING TO DO WITH THE
ENFORCEMENT. WITH RESPECT TO
THE OUT OF STATE- OPTICAL
COMPANY. YOU KNOW IT SEEMS TO
ME IFTHE LAW IS CLEAR AND
CONSTITUTIONAL. IS THERE NOT
SOME INJUNCTIVE RELIEF SOME
SHUT DOWN. ORDER AUTHORITY THAT
CAN BE PURSUED FOR. OUT OF
STATE COMPANIES WHO DEFY. WHAT
WE DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR DOES WITH WITH RESPECT
TO PUTTING LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
IS THAT BEING PURSUED WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. YES SO- WE
ARE CONTINUING TO WORK THE
CITATIONS THEY ARE BEING HEARD-
BY THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS- WE ARE WORKING WITH A
TEAM YOUR DAD IN ORDER TO-
CONTINUE TO PURSUE THE CASE- WE
ARE IN THE APPEAL PROCESS AT
THIS. JUNCTURE. HIWITHOUT
BEING ABOUT WITHOUT BEING A
LAWYER NOT TO JUMP IN A MORE
THAN HER FOR WEARING THE ARE-
BUT WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING TO
ADDRESS THAT MORE IMMEDIATELY-
AND HE'S GONE THROUGH THE
HEARING PROCESS- BUT HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO. MEET IN THAT DOWN-
BUT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE- THE YOU
KNOW OUR OUR OUR- ATTORNEY
GENERAL. LIAISON IS- ARE
ASSIGNED TO DEDICATE- HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH A QUITE DILIGENTLY
I'M QUITE CLOSELY ACTIVELY
INTERACTION IN A MEETING
EARLIER THIS MORNING AT NINE
FIFTEEN WITH OUR DEPARTMENT. WE
ARE- PURSUING ALL LEGAL AVENUES
AND WOULD YOU BRING THAT. OUR
COMPANY INTO COMPLIANCE. WELL I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS IS
CERTAINLY. THE PURVIEW OF THESE
CAN BE BUT- IT JUST OCCURS TO
ME THAT THIS IS PROBABLY A
SOMEWHAT UNIQUE SITUATION AND
IF A- LARGE OUT OF STATE
COMPANY IS. THROWING DOWN THE
GAUNTLET IN CHALLENGING WHAT WE
DO HERE- QUEUING UP OUR
RESOURCES TRYING TO PROSECUTE
AND DEFEND CITATIONS WHEN IN
FACT THE CHALLENGES A MUCH
LARGER WHEN. PERHAPS EVERYBODY
CAN AGREE INCLUDING THE OUT OF
STATE COMPANY THAT THEY WANT TO
CHALLENGE THE RULES SO. MAYBE
WE OUGHT TO GET IT INTO A FORUM
WHERE WE'RE JUST CHALLENGING
THE RULE AND- LINE UP THE
TROOPS AND- MAY THE BEST PERSON
WIN BUT I'LL LEAVE THAT TO YOU
AND TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
FIGURE OUT AND THE BEST OF LUCK
TO YOU. WE'RE ON YOUR SIDE. A
FEW PROCESS QUESTIONS BEFORE I
TURN IT BACK TO MY- COLLEAGUES
IN THE CHAMBER AND THOSE
REMOTELY- IN LOOKING THROUGH
THE BACKGROUND MATERIAL. I KNOW
THAT- THIS BOARD HAS DONE AN
ABSOLUTELY SUPERB JOB IN
MANAGING YOUR FISCAL RESOURCES
AND- MUNSON RESERVE OF FUNDING
IF INCREASED FROM TWELVE POINT
ONE. BACK IN THE FY. TWO SEVEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY SIX AND A HALF MONTHS.
RIGHT NOW BUT THE BACKGROUND
PAPER. NOTES THAT THE BOARD IS
PROJECTING A DEFICIT IN FISCAL
YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE- HOW AND WHY. THERE ARE A
NUMBER- ARE ACTORS HERE- WE ARE
SO VERY THANKFUL TO SHARE LOW-
FOR INCLUDING AN ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT NINE CORRECT THE MERGER
OF OUR TWO FUNDS TO THE
ACCOUNTS REPORT OF COURSE WE
TALK ABOUT OVERSEAS OPTICIAN
THREE AN OPTOMETRY AND THAT'S
HAVE BEEN SEPARATE- FOR
INSTANTLY FIFTEEN WE WERE GIVEN
THE AUTHORITY FOR MEDICAL BOARD
TO OVERSEE OF THE PROFESSION.
BOB WE- ARE NOW LOOKING AT
PROJECTIONS IN BUDGET DOCUMENTS
THAT INCLUDE THE MERGER OF THE
FUND- AND SO WE ARE ON A STABLE
FOOTING WE HAVE A LARGER
PROJECTION OF ONE CONVERTER- OF
COURSE YOU KNOW YOU COULD
CONFIRM THAT THE COMING
TOGETHER TO PROGRAMS- INTO- OUR
SONS GATHERED- UNDERCOVER STING
BY THE PROGRAMS THAT WE WILL BE
DOING A SHERIFF COSTS- SURVEY
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE- ARE
SUPPORTING ADMINISTRATIVE AND
YOU KNOW A LOT. ENFORCEMENT
MIGHT BE GREAT- FROM BOTH LIKE
TO STREAM AT THAT I JUST WANT
TO SAY TO THAT IS THAT IS SUCH
A HUGE- BILLION FOR IRAQ
ADMINISTRATIVELY- EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY SIX BECAUSE WE HAVE AT
THIS POINT ONE ANALYST IN OUR
DEPARTMENT UNIT WHO- IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION PAPERS AND YOU'LL
SEE THAT- IN OUR LICENSING
NUMBERS ARE NUMBERS OF LICENSES
FOR OPTOMETRISTS OPTICIANS IS
ACTUALLY PRETTY CLOSE TO THE
SAME- AND SO WE THOUGHT ONE
ANALYST TO OVERSEE THE WHOLE
PROGRAM YOU HAVE A CASELOAD
THAT TWICE THAT. OF THE OTHER
ANALYSTS WHO WERE WORKING OUT
TIME FOR CASES THAT WE'RE STILL
VERY THANKFUL TO CHAIR LOW FOR-
GIVING US THE FLEXIBILITY TO
FIND TO MERGE THE FUNDS WHICH
WILL ALLOW US TO SEARCH OUR
WORKFORCE TO BE- IT MOST NEEDED
AREAS ON AS OPPOSED TO BEING
STOPPED BY THIS PROGRAM
CONSTRAINTS. SO WE'RE WE'RE
UNDERNEATH WHILE WE'RE ON. I
PROBABLY OUGHT TO GO TO ONE OF
YOUR MEMBERS AND YOUR GLASSES
DON'T WORK SO WELL I WAS
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT THE
OPTICIAN FUND CONDITION AND NOT
THE OPTOMETRY FUND CONDITION IN
AT FOUR POINT TWO MONTHS IN
RESERVE YOU ARE IN FACT- IF NOT
BORDERING ON. A PROBLEM
EXPERIENCING A PROBLEM THAT
WILL NEED TO BE ADDRESSED SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND- I APOLOGIZE FOR MAKING YOU
MAKE THEM. LET ME TURN TO-
CONTINUING EDUCATION AT THIS
POINT- THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE%
THAT IS UNIQUE TO YOU FOR ALL
APPARENTLY IN THE HEALTHCARE
AREA. YOU- I ASSUME REQUIRE
YOUR MEMBERS TO SELF CERTIFY
RIGHT WITH RESPECT TO
COMPLETION OF- CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS. YES WE
DID THAT STATION AT THE TIME OF
RENEWAL SO I WAS I WAS TAKEN BY
THE COMMENTS IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER IF I HAVEN'T MISSED READ
THESE. THAT THERE WAS AN AUDIT
AND THERE WAS A FAILURE RATE OF
31% IN OTHER WORDS. 31%
APPARENTLY OF THOSE AUDITED.
FAILED TO COMPLETE THEIR SEALY
REQUIREMENTS. AND I ASSUME
THAT'S AFTER OF SELF
CERTIFICATION. DID I READ THAT
THIS ONE CORRECTLY. YES YES
THEY'RE ROBBING YOU CAN YOU
READ THE BUDGET NUMBERS OF
RECKLESS AS WELL BUT NOW WE'VE
GOT A COMBINED FORTY BUT THE
OFFICE YOU KNOW SH I'M YEAH WE
AT. FELT AT. AND WE ARE AND
TRIED ALL BETWEEN BY THE ABOUT
5% OF OUR- LATELY BE ON ABOUT
THEIR ACT BUT THEY WILL GO BACK
TO THAT AND SAY THANK FOR
TRYING TO THEIR PLEASE GIVE A
THE RECORD STILL THE YOU DID
THAT I MEAN HAD A HIGH THAT
PROBABLY 31% FAILURE RATE. I'M
AND I'M GONNA GET LOT MORE AT
THE BOARD FAVORITE BUT MIGHTY-
WE NOT BEEN ABLE PRIORITY OUR
C. E. AUDIT- WE- AN IMPORTANT.
AND WE ARE CURRENTLY- GOING THE
PROCESS TO HIRE RETIRED UNIT
ACROSS TRAINING AND BRING ALL
ITS TRANSFER. PROPELLANT ARE
IMPORTANT BASS. SO WE'RE
BRINGING IN MORE RESOURCES JULY
ONE IF WE CAN'T- IN ORDER TO
DEDICATE TRADEMARK VOTE. THAT
WERE ABLE TO HAVE. MORE OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT ANALYSTS WORKING ON
THOSE ON IT SHOULD COME AS
OPPOSED TO BEING. I LOVED WITH
ONE PERSON AND WHEN THAT PERSON
LEAVES- YOU KNOW I NEED TO
BACKFILL THAT- KNOWLEDGE AND-
YEAH OPERATION OF THE BOARD. SO
WE REALIZED THAT IT IT. THE
BILL RATE IS. GOING ON AT WORK
MORE REACH THAN- YEAH COMPUTER
PERFORMING THE IT. WELL
ACTUALLY MIKE MICHAEL WAS NOT
MEANT TO BE CRITICAL. OF MICRO
ACTUALLY COMP. THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE DOING AUDITS AND YOU
DISCOVER THAT FOLKS. APPARENTLY
CERTIFIED THAT THEY'VE
COMPLETED THEIR SEALY OR NOT C.
L. E. THAT'S ME. US CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS AND THEN
THEY DON'T SO I THINK YOU'RE
DOING A FINE JOB OBVIOUSLY MORE
IS BETTER AND THANK YOU FOR
TRYING TO WORK ON THAT. MY
QUESTION GOES TO AND IT COMES
FROM MY BACKGROUND BOTH AS A
MILITARY GUY IN MY PAST. AND I
ONCE WAS A LAWYER. AND
CERTIFICATIONS- HAVE MEANING.
TO MOST PEOPLE. AND SO WHEN YOU
HAVE AN OPTOMETRIST TO
CERTIFIES THAT THEY HAVE
COMPLETED CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS AND THEN YOU AUDIT
AND 31% OF THEM HAVING
CERTIFIED THAT THEY'VE DONE THE
JOB THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
YOU FIND THAT THEY HAVE NOT I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM AND I NOTICE IN
THE BACKGROUND PAPER THEY'RE
SUBJECT TO A CITATION OR FORMAL
DISCIPLINE. I WOULD ASSUME THAT
IF INTEGRITY BEING WHAT IT IS
AND YOU WILL HAVE TO CHARGE
CONDITIONS AND WE DEPEND ON
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS TO
CHART ACCURATELY AND WHAT THEY
PUT DOWN AS WHAT THEY SEE WHAT
HAPPENS TO THESE PEOPLE THE 31%
OF THEM WHO. SAY THEY DID IT
BUT DIDN'T DO IT. YEAH YOU KNOW
WE USED TO LIKE MY MOTHER MY
MOTHER USED TO SAY IF YOU KNOW
OF THOSE WHO LIVE WILL CHEAT
RIGHT. SO. SO WHAT WE FIND IN
OUR AUDIT THAT THAT 31% FAILURE
DOESN'T INCLUDE THOSE WHO. WISH
I THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
ATTENDING A SESSION THAT WAS-
EITHER WOULD WOULD COUNT TOWARD
THIRTY THING EDUCATION BUT IN
FACT IT HADN'T BEEN VERIFIED BY
COKE- THE NATIONAL. OR BY THE
BOARD ITSELF- AND SO THAT WAS
YOU KNOW A MISTAKE ON THEIR
PART WE ASK THEM TO GO BACK
AND- CORRECT THAT GOING WE TAKE
THE NUMBER OF UNITS THAT THEY
THOUGHT THEY WERE DEALING BY
ATTENDING ANOTHER- WORKSHOPS
AND TO DO THAT WORK IN A
CERTAIN TIME PERIOD USUALLY
THIRTY TO SIXTY DAYS DEPENDING
ON THE NUMBER- THE- PREDATOR
MISTAKE- AND- THEN YOU KNOW. IT
ALSO. BE SURE THAT THIS WILL BE
A PART OF WHAT YOUR SHOULD BE
DOING GOING FORWARD REMEMBER
THIS IS OUR MEDIATION- WE TELL
THEM UNTIL. WE ASK THAT THEY-
QUICKLY FINISH THOSE- UNIT BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN HADN'T THE BILL.
ON EIGHT EIGHT ARE. THE INCLUDE
RARITY THAT WE GET SOME WHO HAS
JUST FALSE- BUT WE FIRST WORK
IN THE IF YOU ACTION WE WORK TO
GET THEM TO COME- ETHICALLY
FORTY THAT THAT ISN'T-
HAPPENING. WE HAVE COURSE ARE
TO BE BACK TO. OUR PORTAL TO.
IN ORDER GET THE EXACTLY IF YOU
CAN HOLD PUBLIC TOWN AND I KNOW
THE WE'VE GOT- PRACTITIONERS
ARE WILLING TO CHEAT THEIR OWN
THE AND POSSIBLY. WHEN THEY'RE
DEALING THE FOR TAX OF THE
PRINTER THAT IS VERY VERY HIGH
AND ABSOLUTE CAN THAT OCCUR I
COULD SEE HOW THAT COULD HAPPEN
WHERE YOU THINK YOU'RE PICKING
A COURSE THAT QUALIFIES. IT
DOESN'T QUITE. OR YOU THINK YOU
HAVE TWENTY FIVE HOURS BUT YOU
ONLY HAVE TWENTY FOUR POINT
FIVE. AND I'M PLEASED TO HEAR
THAT YOU SAY THAT THE ONES THAT.
CLEARLY YOU'RE TRYING TO GAME
THE SYSTEM ARE VERY VERY FEW
AND THAT'S A THAT'S COMFORTING
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
INFORMATION. ON THE IN THE AREA
OF- ENFORCEMENT AND COST
RECOVERY OF THIS THIS QUESTION
BEFORE AND IF IT'S NOT AN
INTELLIGENT QUESTION IT'S VERY
POSSIBLE THAT IT'S NOT AND YOU
CAN LET ME KNOW. I HAVE THICK
SKIN BUT- WE HAVE A CHART IN%
OUR BACKGROUND PAPER THAT TALKS
ABOUT POTENTIAL CASES FOR COST
RECOVERY IN CASES. WHERE
RECOVERY- WHAT RECOVERY WAS
ORDERED. HELLO I'M TRYING AND
THEN THE AMOUNT COLLECTED AND
I'M TRYING TO GET A HANDLE ON
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR COST
RECOVERY PROGRAM AND WHAT I
THINK IS MISSING IN IS WHAT
WERE THE ENFORCEMENTEXPENSES
IN CASES WHERE RECOVERY WAS
AUTHORIZED. SO I CAN MEASURE
THE COST RECOVERY AGAINST THE
EXPENSES IN CASES WHERE COST
RECOVERY WAS AUTHORIZED AS
OPPOSED TO TOTAL EXPENSES DOES
THAT MAKE SENSE. AND YOU MAY
NOT HAVE THIS IT MAY BE A MIS
READ THIS CHART AND IF SO YOU
CAN LET ME KNOW BUT IF I
HAVEN'T MAYBE IF NOT NOW AT
SOME POINT YOU CAN LET ME KNOW.
HOW THOSE COSTS. MEASURE UP.
YEAH YEAH I THINK THAT THIS IS
A VERY MUCH INTELLIGENT
QUESTIONS THERE ARE THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT TO ME- AT THE
END WE HAVE HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THIS CHART
AND AROUND PROJECTED BIRTH
COLLECTED COST RECOVERY. ALSO
THE ISSUE RATE THAT WE AND OUR
COST RECOVERY DON'T ACCOUNT FOR
THE TIME OUR ANALYSTS TO DO
THAT INVESTIGATION- SO HEIR
COST RECOVERY ISN'T A TRUE-
ESTIMATION OF WHAT. THE BOARD
ACTUALLY PUT INTO- EIGHT
BRINGING THIS CASE TO- TO
CLOSER- BUT I WILL NOT MAKE UP
RIGHT THERE. WE'RE TO GET NEW
WORDS STAY IN MY LANE- I THINK
YOU KNOW IT IF YOU DON'T MIND-
RECORD THING THAT THE NUMBER OF
THE CHART- WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO
IS TO GO BACK TO WITH OUR
ENFORCEMENT STAFF. COMMENTED
POSSIBLY FOLLOW UP WITH- BEING
HE- HE HE BE ON THE BAK IN
ORDER TO GIVE YOU MORE COMPLETE
ANSWER- SURE IT IS. ARE YOU
SURE THAT I'M LOOKING AT THE-
WHY I'M LOOKING AT A MY PAY
NUMBERING IS THE SAME AS THE
ONE THAT'S SUPPOSED IS PAID
FIFTEEN. OF THIRTY THREE PAGE.
OF THIRTY THREE ON THE BACK ROW
MATERIAL. AND IT LISTS EXAMPLE
AN EFFORT TWENTY. TWENTY TOTAL
ENFORCEMENT EXPENDITURES.
POTENTIAL CASES FOR RECOVERY.
CASES RECOVERY ORDERED AMOUNT
OF COST RECOVERY ORDERED SEVEN-
THIS IS AN THOUSAND SO. I
ASSUME IT'S A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND. AND THEN THE
AMOUNT COLLECTED. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND AND I'M JUST
TRYING TO THIS ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR COST
RECOVERY. IN THOSE CASES WHERE
COST RECOVERY IS AUTHORIZED SO
I SORT OF NEED TO KNOW THE
TOTAL EXPENSES IN THOSE CASES
VERSUS THE TOTAL EXPENSES.
SHEPHERD SURE I COULD STOP ME A
FIRE TRUCK IF I PUT MY FOOT IN
MY MOUTH BUT YOU KNOW SOME OF
OUR MORE EGREGIOUS CASES MORE
MORE MORE EXPENSIVE CASES ARE.
WHERE THE- LICENSEE. JUST IT
IS. WHAT GIVES UP THEIR
LICENSE. AND WE NEVER HEAR FROM
AGAIN THOSE CASES ARE- GREGIS
PROBABLY. ARE VERY EXPENSIVE
BUT ARE NOT THE KIND OF CASE
THAT WE CAN CHASE AFTER THOSE
PEOPLE SAFE GIVEN UP THEIR
LICENSES I UNDERSTAND THAT SO I
CLEARLY UNDERSTAND THAT OKAY
THANK YOU I JUST WAS TRYING TO.
TRYING TO. ONCE THE PERCENTAGES
HERE AND I WASN'T SURE THAT I
HAVE THE RIGHT DATA IN ORDER TO
DO IT AND IF I DO JUST JUST LET
ME KNOW. AND THEN I'M GOING TO
STOP TALKING HERE AND ONE
MICROSECOND BUT- I'VE ASKED
THIS QUESTION OF OTHER BOARDS
AS WELL. AND I WHAT I'M TRYING
TO GET A HANDLE ON IN TERMS OF
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATION AND
DISCIPLINE. IS THE LENGTH OF
TIME THAT IT TAKES. TO PROCESS
A CASE ONCE TO AN INVESTIGATION
HAS CONCLUDED. THAT A DECISION
IS MADE TO PROCEED WITH
DISCIPLINARY ACTION. AND I SEE
THE TARGET ON PAGE THIRTEEN OF
OUR MATERIAL IS FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY DAYS WHICH SEEMS TO
BE CONSISTENT BUT AS I RECALL
THE- DISCIPLINARY THE
BACKGROUND PAPERS IS
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS TOOK SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX DAYS TO
COMPLETE FOR COMPLAINTS AGAINST
OPTOMETRISTS. AND MIKE I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS THAT IN TOTAL OR
IS THAT FROM THE DATE THE
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETED TO
THE DATE THE DISCIPLINARY
ACTION IS FINISHED. I'M NOT
SURE THEY UNDERSTAND THE TWO
DIFFERENCES THAT IN TOTAL. FOUR
EIGHT THAT YOU GIVE ME YOUR I'M
I'M CONFUSED AND WALDRON WHAT I
WHAT I'VE ASKED OTHER ANOTHER
IN OTHER SITUATIONS WITH OTHER
BOARDS I'M TRYING TO. FIGURE
OUT WHERE THE DELAY OCCURS. AND
IN ORDER TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE DELAY OCCURS I HAVE TO HAVE
THE PROCESS BROKEN DOWN AND
MAYBE THIS IS BRETT HAS BEEN
BROKEN DOWN. SO I'M TRYING TO
DECIDE IF ONE THE TARGET THE
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY DAYS. IS
MEASURED FROM THE DATE THE
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETED TO
THE DATE THE DISCIPLINARY
ACTION IS COMPLETED. AND IN THE
SPECIFIC CASE OF YOU. THE SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX DAYS TO
COMPLETE. DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS
INVOLVING COMPLAINTS AGAINST A
TIME INTEREST. IS THAT MEASURED
FROM THE DATE THE INVESTIGATION
HAS BEEN COMPLETED TO THE DATE.
STARTING FROM THE DATE THE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION STARTS. TO
THE DAY THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
FROM THE- AND IT COULD BE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. BUT I
DON'T KNOW SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
THIS IS NOT- THIS IS NOT A
JEOPARDY SO YOU CAN- IF YOU CAN
PROVIDE ME KNOW YOU'RE RUNNING
LATER. I WON'T LIE TO BALKO
ANOTHER TO ATTRACT NEW FRIENDS.
AND GOT MY CHAT JOKES MY
IMPORTANT OR- BY AS ASSIST
ANYTHING ABOUT THEIR USED TO BE
A FIFTY YARD. BURKE THE LEADER
IS FOR MY NEW YEAR'S ISN'T SO
IT IS A DAY THAT THE KEY- TODAY
THE IT IS- IT BUT THE JUST THE
HAS BEEN. METED OUT I SEE I SEE
WILL WE'LL WE'LL DIG DEVELOPING.
MOVED DIG DOWN WITH STAFF AND
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THE DELAY IS AND IF THE
DELAY IS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND I'LL- TURN MY FOCUS
TO THE DOJ AND TALK TO THE DOJ
ABOUT WHAT THEIR PROCESS IS IF.
THE DELAY IS- IF THERE'S SOME
DELAYS ON ON THE PART OF THE
BOARD THEN I'LL COME BACK IN.
AND TALK TO YOU ALL BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR
RESPONSES AND YOUR PATIENCE.
PATIENTS WITH ME. COLLEAGUES
OPPOSE FOR THE DIALOGUE EDITOR.
I AM CLEARLY FINISHED ANY OTHER
ARE SURE LOW. CENTER PAN GOOD
TO HAVE YOU WITH US THANK YOU
THANK YOU- THANK YOU TERRA AND-
AND I APPRECIATE THE- RIGHT I
DID WANT TO GO BACK IN TOUCH ON
THIS IS THE-CONTINUING
EDUCATION I KNOW THAT- SARRAF
ASKED A QUESTION ABOUT THE-
HIGH FAILURE RATE WHICH-
ACTUALLY WILL. I APPRECIATE
YOUR EXPLANATION I THINK IT
DOES STILL REPRESENT  SYSTEM
FAILURE THAT- A THIRD OF A
CENTURY 31% EVERYONE THE
AUDITED DIDN'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT SEAT THEY NEED TO DO. AND
SO PERHAPS IT NEEDS TO BE MORE
CLARITY TO THE OPTOMETRY
COMMUNITY AS TO WHAT TO SEE
REQUIREMENTS ACTUALLY ARE IF
THEY DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THEIR
COURSES THEY TOOK DIDN'T FIT
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS. ACCORDING
TO THE BOARD BUT I ALSO WOULD
MAKE NOTE OF THAT- IS MENTIONED
HERE. THAT THERE ARE ONLY THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE AUDITS OVER
THE PAST FOUR PASSED FOR FISCAL
YEAR SO THAT MEANS THE ONLY
AUDITED EIGHTY. FOR WEALTHY.
YOU CAN ON AVERAGE EIGHTY PER
YEAR THEY'VE MADE AND SOME
VARIATIONS BETWEENYEARS YET
ALSO YOU REPORTED YOU DUDE.
TWELVE THOUSAND. RENEWALS
ANNUALLY. WHICH MEANS YOU'RE
ONLY AUDITING POINT 7% OF ALL
THE- PEOPLE WHO ARE IN DOING ON
AVERAGE- IN TERMS OF YOU SEE
AUDITS AND- EVEN WITH ONLY
POINT SEVEN YOU STILL FOUND
THIRTY ONE PERCENT. WITH CCL
YEARS- AND I THINK IT BROUGHT
THIS UP AT THE LAST REVIEW IS
THERE SOME INTENT TO PERHAPS I
MEAN AGAIN THE ONLY DODD
EVERYBODY NECESSARILY BUT
PERHAPS OF LARGER SAMPLE SIZE
TEN POINT 7% ESPECIALLY SINCE
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE SUCH A HIGH
FAILURE RATE- AND IF IT'S- IN
AGAIN. IF IT'S BECAUSE PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW WHICH CEDAR SUPPOSED
TO TAKE PERHAPS YOU SHOULD TAKE
THAT USE THAT FEEDBACK TO
IMPROVE THE COMMUNICATION SO
THAT WE SEE AN IMPROVEMENT AND
THE COMPLIANCE RATE WITH. WITH
THE COMMUNICATION REQUIREMENTS
SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO YOUR PLANS
FOR. AUDITS INTO THE FUTURE IN
TERMS OF THE RATE THE
PERCENTAGE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
PLANT AUDIT OF THE RENEWALS.
YOUR TARGET FOR EACH YEAR IT'S
5% AND IN SOME OF THE FACTS
FOUR. YEARS WE HAD LET OUR 5%
EACH YEAR- AND IN FACT WE'VE
HAD. ANY IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
WHAT LOSS OF STAFF- HERE WE
HAVE NOT BEEN A TO- YEAH. THE
EQUINE ON IT I'M A BIT THE
NATION BEFORE- WE THE L.
NATALIE RECOGNIZED- WHO JUST
WALK AGAIN ANOTHER SENIOR STAFF
WORK WITHOUT NUMBER- IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS BUT- WE
ARE HIRING TO BACK FILL THAT ON
A AND E'S OSTACLE YOU'RE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. I'M MORE OPERATE BRING
INTENT HEALTH LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT I'M ALSO CURRENTLY
GOING THROUGH THE HIRING
PROCESS BUT WHICH HIRED A NEW
WITH COMPLETELY WHAT I WANNA DO
IS. MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT THE
HELP THAT WE GOT CROSS TRAINING
ACROSS MORE EXACT. UNTIL IT'S
NOT VIOLATE ONE ONE PERSON LEAD
THE PROGRAM. IT'S JUST NO
LONGER UP. UNTIL WE ANTICIPATE
A LOT OF THE LATTER. OF
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY.
TRAINING AT- AND- PRODUCE MORE
OF THE TRAINING PROCESS AND THE
CONTINUING THAT IS- PORTION OF
MORE JACK I'M NOT A FIVE ACROSS.
OKAY SO HEAR THE GOLD FIVE FOR
A YEAR WHICH IS KIND OF SIMILAR
TO OTHER BOY BUT- I WOULD MAKE
NO THAT. AND YET I APPRECIATE
YOUR- ISSUES- DEALER IT SPIN
QUITE A FEW YEARS ARE READY SIR-
AND I BROUGHT IT UP THE LAST
REVIEW SO- HOPEFULLY THIS'LL BE
MORE OF A- IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO GET TO THAT 5% ANDY AND THEN
AGAIN AS I MENTIONED- ALSO
BETTER EITHER BUT WE NEED TO
CLARIFY THE REQUIREMENTS OR DO
SOME OTHER THING BECAUSE THE
31% FAILURE RATE EVEN IF IT
TURNS OUT YEAH AND IT IS
PROBLEMATIC SOMEWHERE
SOMETHING'S GONE WRONG
SOMEWHERE THERE SO IT'S EITHER
THE APPLICANTS ARE DOING IT.
BUT YOU'RE SAYING THAT THERE'S
SOME RISK UNDERSTANDING THAN WE
NEED BETTER COMMUNICATION THE
OTHER QUESTION ABOUT THE C. E.
IS THAT. DOING EDUCATION IS
THAT DO YOU HAVE DOES THE BOARD
HAVE ANY POLICY OR THERE ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO CERTIFIED THE C.
E. AND TERMS OF ENSURING THAT
THERE ARE CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
BETWEEN THE PEOPLE PRESENTING
THE C. E. THAT THEY'LL HAVE
FINANCIAL CONFLICTS SO WE WANNA
BE SURE DISCONTINUING EDUCATION
NOT A MARKETING OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE AT. TEACHING
THIS. HE SPEAK TO A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST POLICIES FOR
CONTINUING EDUCATION. SO I CAN.
TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THAT
QUESTION- BEFORE I BECAME THE
PRESIDENT BORE I SERVED ON THE-
ON THE SPROXIL EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AND THAT COMMITTEE
REVIEWS ALMOST ALL THE-
PRESENTATIONS BEFORE THEY'RE
APPROVED- INCLUDING THE
SPEAKERS THEIR BACKGROUNDS. AND
THE MATERIALS THE ACTUAL POWER
POINTS- THAT WILL BE PRESENTED.
OUR SHARE IS A AT UC BERKELEY
OPTOMETRY PROFESSOR. AND AS YOU
MIGHT GUESS- DEFINITION OF
EDUCATION IS PRETTY HOT. AND I
CAN SAY BASED ON MY SERVICE ON
THE PRACTICING EDUCATION
COMMITTEE- THE BOARD MEMBERS ON
THAT COMMITTEE ARE ARE NOT
GOING TO IMPROVE SOME YELP
SALES JOB YOU KNOW SOME AMWAY
OR AYE DON'T WANT TO DISCOURAGE
FAMILY BUT I'VE BEEN YOU KNOW
COAXED INTO THESE YOU KNOW
MARKETING SCHEMES THAT THAT
WITHOUT. WITHOUT BEINGINFORMED
AT THE OUTSET SO WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE MATERIALS AND I BELIEVE
REJECTED FROM SOME-
PRESENTATIONS BECAUSE IT DOES
LOOK LIKE MARKETING AND WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON IT HAS TO BE
EDUCATION. SO I APPRECIATE THAT
WORKS DONE I THINK COULD BE
HELPFUL SINCE OF THE BOARD HAS
THAT ROLE IN REVIEWING AND
APPROVING- CONTINUING
EDUCATION. THAT PERHAPS THERE
SHOULD BE SOME BOARD POLICY AS
WELL THAT- BACKS UP THIS
ACTIVITY. REGARDING DISCLOSING
FINANCIAL INTERESTS AND OF
COURSE- BE SURE THAT THERE'S
CLEARLY FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TAKING THESE COURSES THAT IT
OKAY BEEN REVIEWED FOR THESE
FINANCIAL CONFLICTS OF THERE
ARE. EITHER DEAD THEY'RE NOT
PROVED OR ALSO IF- IF IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S NOT SIGNIFICANT
ENOUGH TO BE OF MAJOR CONCERN
BUT STILL THAT PEOPLE ARE
DISCLOSING THE POTENTIAL
FINANCIAL CONFLICTS TO THE
LEARNERS. UP FRONT- SO IF YOU
CAN I THINK DEVELOPING SUCH A
POLICY. TO HELP REINFORCE WHAT
SOUNDS LIKE MAY YOUR BOARD
MEMBERS RATE DOING I THINK
WOULD BE HELPFUL- KNOWING THAT
THERE'S GOING TO TURN OVER ON.
BOARDS AS WELL SO SURE SURE
OKAY AND THEN ONE JUST ONE
OTHER QUESTION- REGARDING CHILD
AND ISSUE SEVENTEEN CHILDHOOD
VISION SCREENINGS. I'M A P. I
TAKE CARE CHILDREN DISOBEY-
OBVIOUSLY VISION SCREENINGS
VERY IMPORTANT- WHILE WE'RE
CLOSELY WITH OPTOMETRISTS ON
THAT. I ALSO WANT ALSO BE SURE
WE'RE DOING EVIDENCE BASED
SCREENING SO WE'RE NOT- YOU.
AND SO I THINK THAT- HOPEFULLY
IN ADDRESSING- CHILDHOOD VISION
SCREENINGS AND AT LEAST FOR THE
BOARD'S ROLE IN THAT THAT-
YOU'LL BE WORKING WITH PEOPLE
IN- THE- LEARNING DISABILITIES
AND OTHER DISABILITIES
COMMUNITY AND WITH PHYSICIANS
AND OTHER PEOPLE AND OTHER
PROFESSIONALS TAKING CARE OF
THESE CHILDREN. COMING UP WITH
A- REASONABLE- WAY TO BE SURE
THAT CHILDREN ARE VISION SCREENIKNOW THAT SCHOOLS DO THAT
PEDIATRICIANS DO THAT OBVIOUSLY
WE DON'T DO IT AT THE SAME WITH
THE SAME LEVEL AS AS
OPTOMETRISTS BUT YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A PRIVATE BROADER
DISCUSSION TO ENSURE THAT WE DO
SCREEN CHILDREN FOR- VISION
DEFECTS. THAT ARE APPROPRIATE
AND OTHER THAN SPACED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR PAN MEMBERS ANY
OTHER CENTER CHIRLA. YES I'D
LIKE TO GO BACK IF I CAN'T TO
THE QUESTION ABOUT AUDIT THESE
AUDIT SHOULD WE TALK ABOUT- OR
THE LACK THEREOF ARE. WHICH
TRIGGERS THE AUDIT IS AT AN
INVESTIGATION. OF A COMPLAINT
WOULD INVESTIGATION BROUGHT
APART BECAUSE THE COMPLAINT.
WHAT IS A SEQUENCE THERE. SO IF
YOU HAVE HAD A PREVIOUS
VIOLATION- YOU WERE AUDITED AT
RANDOM- AND WE FOUND THAT THERE
WAS A COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEE I
REQUIREMENTS. THEN YOU CAN BE
THROWN BACK IN. TO BE BE
AUDITED MORE QUICKLY BUT-
BEGINNING OF THAT THE BASICALLY
A RANDOM- PICKING OUT OF THE
FIVE PERCENT- THE- APPLICANT I
THINK I'LL DO IT WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE RIGHT NUMBERS BECAUSE NOT
ALL OF OUR TWELVE THOUSAND- YOU
KNOW WE WILL BE EACH YEAR
REQUIRED CONTINUING EDUCATION
OUR OBJECTIONS THAT WORK AT
THAT POINT DO NOT REQUIRE
CONTINUING EDUCATION SO- AND
THEN OF COURSE- YOU KNOW OUR
OUR OPTICAL DISPENSING
BUSINESSES. I ALSO DON'T
REQUIRE EDUCATION- AND YOU'LL-
DON'T REQUIRE COMPLETE
EDUCATION AND WHERE YOU'LL-
RESEARCH MAKE IT OUTSIDE OF A
LOCAL ONE I DON'T LOOK SURGERY.
I DON'T APPLY THE JURY
EDUCATION ARE A LITTLE BIT THAN
FALL THOUSAND SO I THINK WE'RE
A LITTLE BIT THAT IS NOT SEVEN.
ALTHOUGH IT THAT IT IS
CERTAINLY YEAR WE'VE HAD THE
FIVE YEARS WE HAVE BEEN ABLE DO
THE OTHER- AND SO TRIGGERED
THAT EFFECT. HAVE IN THE PAST-
AND ENFORCEMENT ANALYST ARE
DEDICATED- AT THE END OF THE
YEAR OR DURING DOWNTIME ONLY
FIVE PERCENT- ALL OF THE
APPLICATIONS THAT WE RECEIVE
BETWEEN THAT HERE A LITTLE BIT
THE TWELVE CALENDAR MONTHS
BEFORE ON IN ORDER TO RANDOMLY
THEN CONTACT THE LIGHTENED B.
ASK THEM FOR THE OCCUPATION- OF
THEIR CONTINUING EDUCATION
UNITS AND THEN THE VERIFY THAT
THOSE ARE COURSES EITHER OFFICE
MICHAEL PORTER HAS THAT- I'M.
SURPRISED BY DEFAULT. THANK YOU
MISTER. OKAY THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA MEMBERS IN THE OTHER
CHIRLA. SOME MEMBER OR ONE. I
DON'T THINK AND I HAD TO LEAVE
FOR A CO OF MINUTES HOPEFULLY I
DIDN'T MISS THIS- HOW MANY
VACANCIES YOU HAVE ON YOUR
ORDER RIGHT NOW. WE JUST GOT A
PLAYER FROM THE SENATE SO SURE
WHAT'S THE NUMBER NOW. WE ARE
STILL AT- TWO CHOCOLATE MAKE IT.
I DO BELIEVE- AND ONE
PROFESSIONAL THEY CAN BE- AND
SPECTACLE IN THE CENTER CONTACT
WITH THE CONCERT. IT AND THE
WE'VE GOT THROUGH A LOT OF
THESE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS- THIS
YEAR AND THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
COMMON THEME ON ALL THE SPORTS
IS- SICKENING SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF VACANCIES AND
ESPECIALLY PUBLIC MEMBERS WHICH
I THINK. DOES PUT YOU AT RISK
SO COULD YOU EXPLAIN TO ME TO-
YOU KNOW FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
WHY ARE THERE SO MANY VACANCIES
WHY ARE THESE POSITIONS SO
DIFFICULT TO FILL AND- IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO AS A
LEGISLATURE TO- ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. WOULD YOU LIKE IT TO
TALK WITH THAT OR DID YOU WANT
TO GIVE A COMMENT- WHY DON'T
YOU START I HAVE TO COLLECT MY
THOUGHTS. SO- WE IN THE BOARD
R. T. REALLY DOING OUTREACH IN
ORDER TO RECRUIT FOR THE
PUBLIC- OPENING- YOU KNOW DOWN
THE LEG SIDE WHERE WE GOT A
WEBSITE HOSTING WE SEND IT OUT-
YOU KNOW REGULARLY THROUGH OUR
LIST- WE'RE DOING SOCIAL MEDIA-
CAMPAIGNS AROUND IT- IN FACT.
I'VE HEARD THAT WORK ON THE
LAST- PRESIDENT'S MESSAGE
QUARTERLY PRESIDENT MESSAGE
SPOKE TO THAT AS WELL THE NEED
TO RECRUIT- AND THEN I'LL PUT
AN OPPORTUNITY OF. BLOOD TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK AT THE- COVERED
AUTOMATICALLY. HOUSE OF
DELEGATES. BUT AND TO DO A CALL
AGAIN- YOU KNOW WITH THAT WE
LOOKING FOR. LAND ARE YOU KNOW
I THINK IT MAY BE A GREAT. BUT
I ANSWERING THAT THEN I CAN
GIVE SOME CRAZY OUR PRESENT
MARK OR OTHER BOARD MEMBER IT
IS A BIG COMMITMENT. ON A IF
YOU A PUBLIC MEMBERS WHO. IS
NOT INTO. IN QUALITY AREA- YOU
KNOW EIGHT EIGHT IT'S A BIG.
AND EVERYONE TO WEAR THE- I
THINK THAT EIGHT THE KIND THAT
I DIDN'T THE WARDEN. YOU KNOW
HERE I THINK THE PROCESS HAS
GOTTEN BETTER- I FEEL LIKE THE
THEY GOT NESTOR. IN REALLY YOU
KNOW WORKING. MORE AND MORE
EFFECTIVE FIGURE WHAT THE NEW
ARE THEY JUST AND FILL THOSE- I
YOU KNOW IT IT. PUBLIC SERVICE.
RIGHT- BUT WORKING. TO DO
OUTREACH NINE. FROM THAT
GOVERNOR. I HAD. WORKING WITH
THE PRIVATE AND PARTED WAYS
THEY GO ABOUT TRYING TO FIND
THE CANNABIS. YES I DON'T A
SPECIFIC FOR U. S. M. MEMBER.
YOU KNOW I HARD BACK TO WHEN I
WAS APPOINTED THE SPORT AND IS
THIS ONE OF I HAD A MY LIST OF
WANTING TO BE. COULD BE ON THE
BY THE YOU KNOW IN THE OFFICE
YOU ON A BOARD SAY YES- IT'S
UPCOMING BOARD NOT SO- BUT I
HAVE TO SAY IT WILL I HAVE A
LOT ON ONE CALL. AND GONE ON TO
A BAR SAYS OF THE GROUP'S TALK
ABOUT THE BOARD. I TELL THEM
HOW INTERESTING AND FULFILLING
THIS POSITION IS THE FACT THE
POLICY OF A STATE WIDE LEVEL
YOU YOU CAN IMPROVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE- FOR MY CARE RIGHT
I MEAN I JUST THINK IT MIGHT MY
NINETY YEAR OLD AUNT THAT  WAS
ABLE TO. YOU KNOW OPEN THE DOOR
SO THAT SHE CAN GET- SOME. IN
HOME VISITS SO- I JUST.
ADVERTISE AGAIN THE WORD OUT IT
COULD BE. WORK THAT THAT THAT
THAT THESE BOARDS. AND IT'S NOT
JUST- YOU KNOW LOOKING OVER.
THEY ALSO REGULATIONS. THAT
YEAH THE SECOND PART OF MY
QUESTION WAS IS THERE ANYTHING
WE CAN DO AS THE LEGISLATURE
TO. HOPE THIS ISSUE. REACH OUT
YOUR CONSTITUENTS OR IF YOU
KNOW PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE GREAT
MEMBERS OF THIS BOARD- LET THEM
KNOW HAPPEN CONTACT SHARA OR ME
AND- I'D BE HAPPY TO WALK THEM
THROUGH THE PROCESS TALK TO
THEM ABOUT THE BOARD- AND AT
ABOUT THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT
WE DO. AND YOU KNOW. AS I SAID
TO BEGIN MY REMARKS YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE AN OPTOMETRIST YOU.
MIGHT MIGHT MY QUALIFICATIONS
TO BE ON THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY
WAS. THE THINGS THAT I PUT ON
MY FACE. AND SO I THINK ANYONE
WHO HAS AN INTEREST IN PUBLIC
SERVICE CAN CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
EFFORTS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I THINK IF I ADDED THAT SHE
LED HOLIDAY. NO PLEASE PERCENT
I THINK THAT. I WALDRON FEDERAL.
IRAN I JUST WONDER IF BONTA
DIGITALLY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN WE COULD USE YOUR HELP
AND IN DOING THAT ADVERTISING
SO- HAVING WORKED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND WORKS WITH IT THE
SPEAKER DR NUMBER SERVICES THEY
KNOW THAT ALL OF YOU ARE
DILIGENT ABOUT ON.
COMMUNICATING TO YOUR GUEST. SO
IF YOU'VE GOT A NEW. OR UP. OR
IF THOSE WHO AND- WHERE WOULD
APPROPRIATE PLEASE LET FOLKS
KNOW THE BE THE- ARE THE
INFORMATION IS A- ON OUR
WEBSITE- I AM ALSO MORE THAN
WILLING- HELP. INDIVIDUAL
LEGISLATOR STAFF. IN ORDER TO.
GET THEM WHICH WILL THEY NEED
TO DO THAT BUT WHAT I REALLY IN
THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE YOUR
CONSENT YOU ARE AND- JUST TO
HAVE THE ORDER TO WORK WITH THE
BUSINESS. GREAT PUBLIC SERVICE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
WOULD BE A GREAT BOOST TO THE.
OUTRAGE THAT WE'RE DEALING.
WELL I WAS GONNA SAY BEFORE I
IT OVER TO MIKE. SAID BATES IS.
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN IN BEFORE I
CAME UP HERE I WAS OBVIOUSLY A
FAIRLY ACTIVE IN THE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES IN THE REGION AND-
ORGANIZATIONS AND FRANKLY. IT
MAY HAVE CHANGED BUT CERTAINLY
AT THE TIME AND UP TO THE TIME
I CAME UP HERE. IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT IT
WAS EASY TO FIND THE BOARDS.
AND IT WAS EASY TO FIND THE
NUMBER OF POSITIONS AND WHICH
ONES REPUBLICAN WHICH ONES WERE
NOT. BUT IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT
TO FIND WHICH BOARD SAID
VACANCIES IN WHICH PORTS IN
PARTICULAR HAD PUBLIC
VACANCIES. DIFFICULT TO FIND IT
ON THE WEBSITE SO I'M NOT EVEN
SURE IT AT THAT TIME THAT YOU
COULD. AND YOU HAVE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE YOU HAVE BOARDS OF
REALTORS YOU HAVE A VARIETY OF
ORGANIZATIONS. IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN OUR DISTRICTS
AND AROUND THE STATE. AND IF IN
I'M TALKING TO THE BOARD
PERSONNEL NOW IN YOUR DEALINGS
WITH THE FIRST FLOOR AND WITH
THE APPOINTMENT SECRETARY AND-
THE ADMINISTRATION. I THINK IF
IT IS NOT AVAILABLE READILY
AVAILABLE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WE NEED TO THINK THROUGH
HOW WE PUBLICIZE. IN SOME
EASILY ACCESSIBLE LOCATION. THE
VACANCIES AND OPENINGS FOR OUR
PUBLIC MEMBERS. SO THAT WE CAN
NOT ONLY HELP YOU RECRUIT BUT
THAT CAN COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS OF ALL SORTS
AROUND THE STATE CAN HELP YOU
DO SO. I THINK- I THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY VERY VERY HELPFUL
AGAIN SITUATION MAY HAVE
CHANGED SINCE THE LAST TIME I
TOOK A CLOSE LOOK AT IT BUT IF
NOT. I THINK WE NEED TO TUNE IT
UP A LITTLE BIT. CENTER BATES.
WHEN I NEEDED THEM. I THANK YOU
A VERY VERY INFORMATIVE
DISCUSSION AND LET ME APOLOGIZE
TO MY COLLEAGUES AND CERTAINLY
TO BOARD MEMBERS ARE. BETTER
HERE AND- THE ADMINISTRATIVE-
REPRESENTATIVES I HAD A LITTLE
PLUMBING PROBLEM THIS MORNING
IF I AM GOING AT MY AGING HOUSE-
RIGHT NOW I'M NOT SURE YOU
COVERED THE MOBILE OPTOMETRIC
OFFICES ISSUE ON PAGE THIRTY
ONE OF THIRTY THREE. YEAH AND
IF YOU DID- THEN I CAN GET MY
QUESTIONS ANSWERED- YOU KNOW
SURVEYS THAT YOU HADN'T
GOODNESS YOUR QUESTION IT WAS
COVERED BRIEFLY BUT- YOU MIGHT
COME AT IT FROM A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT DIRECTION SO. WHAT I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALOHA CERTAINLY- HIS WORK IN
THIS FIELD IS BANNED SO- I
NOTED AND IT'S ABOUT THE-
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY SIX AND
TWENTY TWENTY ENACTED AND
WEATHER OUT THERE WAS A REPORT
UPDATING ON THE REAL MAKING FOR
THAT A WHICH IS DUE ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND THE
REASON I BRING IT UP AS THE
MOBILE OPTOMETRIC OFFICES AND
THAT VISION TO LEARN THAT WHOLE
PROGRAM STARTED WHEN I WAS ON
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND IT
WAS SO IMPORTANT AND EFFECTIVE.
IN THE COMMUNITIES ON THAT WERE
LOW INCOME AND UNDERSERVED AND
WE KNOW WHAT OUR KIDS. BACK TO
THAT ISSUE. THAT THEIR- ISSUES
ARE DISCUSSED EARLY ACTS MY
DAUGHTER. AND WE DO LIVE IN A
AREA WE WERE. THAT OF THOSE
ASKING AND SHE WAS. TO HAVE A
VISION PROBLEM WHICH SHE NEVER
REPORTED TO US IN THE EARLY
GRADES THAT SHE WAS HAVING
TROUBLE A PROBLEM SEEN THE
BLACKBOARD. BUT WHEN THEY DID
SOME OF THAT SCHOOL- FROM
REVIEWS AND JOHN TESTING THEY
ARE LET US KNOW THAT SHE HAD A
PROBLEM SO. I JUST FOCUS ON IT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT AND MAKING SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE YOUNG. EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY SIX AND THE RULE
MAKING IS GOING FORWARD AND YOU
MAY HAVEALREADY REPORTED ON
THAT HASSEL YOU CAN MAKE A VERY
BRIEF IF YOU HAVE JUST SO I
UNDERSTAND. OF THAT STUFF OFF
MY QUESTION LIST. WELL I'LL
START INSURANCE YOU CAN
SUMMARIZE OUR EARLY ANCESTORS
AND MY UNDERSTANDING THE
LEGISLATION IS THAT ONCE THE
LEGISLATION PASSED THE. THE
GLOBAL CLINICS WERE. OR A GREEN
LIGHT AND WE HAD THE BOARD HAD
KIND OF A RAMP UP TO WORK ON
THE ON THE REGULATIONS COURSE
THE PANDEMIC- BUT WE'VE TO SURE
AS TO WHAT ADMINISTRATIVE WE
WE'VE BEEN DOING A KEY TO GET
THE RULE MAKING THAT. GREAT
THANK YOU ARE JUST ARE JUST
THAT A SINGLE THANK YOU. KEEP
READING FOR THE CENTER BATES.
NO THAT'S IT THANK YOU THIS IS
WRONG THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION. I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES UP NO HANDS IN THE
AIR NOTHING FROM THOSE WHO ARE
MONITORING THE PRECEDING
REMOTELY SO. LET'S NOT ACCEPT
TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE- BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY. BEGINNING WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NONE WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. BYE SHE NONE MOVING TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ARMOS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT OVER THE
TELEPHONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO BEGIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD HMI PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. WE JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU.
WE
ALMOST HAVE IT I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE DELAY. FORGOTTEN LINE
NUMBER LINE FOURTEEN ONE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CHRISTINE SCHULTZ REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY WE
SUPPORT THE BOARD SUNSET
EXTENSION AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THE BOARD IS DONE OVER
THE PST FOUR YEARS ESPECIALLY
MISS MURPHY SUFFERED IN.
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC. I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE OPEN LINES
OF COMMUNICATION REPORTS THAT.
THERE ARE A FEW ISSUES I'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT. FIRST YOUR
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
ONLINE VISION TESTING THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO FILL IN AYE
GLASSES OR CONTACT LENS
PRESCRIPTION WITHOUT SEEING A
DOCTOR HAS A STRONG POTENTIAL
FOR HARM. THESE TESTS CAN
DIAGNOSE GLAUCOMA I BLOOD
PRESSURE CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
BRAIN TUMORS A NUMBER OF OTHER
CONDITIONS THAT ARE OFTEN
DETECTOR AND I EXAM. WORSE YET
THE WAY SOME OF THESE TESTS ARE
ADVERTISED. THE PATIENT THINKS
THEY HAD AN EYE EXAM. IT'S NOT
HOW MUCH PRESCRIBED. I HAD A
PRESCRIPTION WITHOUT DOING TEST
THE DAY THESE CONDITIONS IT
WOULD BE UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT.
CONTACT LENSES GENERALLY HAVE A
ONE YEAR EXPIRATION FOR A
REASON THEY REQUIRING ANNUAL
MONITORING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT CAUSING ANY
IRRITATION OR SOME OTHER
PROBLEMS WITH THE I. OUR
DOCTORS THE A LOT OF CORNEAL
PROBLEMS BECAUSE OF CONTACT
LENSES THAT ARE NOT WORN
PROPERLY. ONLINE CONTACT LENS
PRESCRIPTION EXTENSIONS MAKE
THIS PROBLEM MUCH WORSE. THE
DOCTORS WHO APPROVED THESE
PRESCRIPTION SHOULDBE HELD TO
THE SAME STANDARD AS IN PERSON
CARE. WE'RE ALSO VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BOARD'S INABILITY TO
ENFORCE THE LAW RELIGIOUS
OPTICIANS. YOU JUST CAN'T HAVE
SOME COMPANY FLAT OUT REFUSED
TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW AND
STILL. OPEN MORE LOCATIONS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE BOARD AND THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE COMING. FEW MONTHS IN
FIND SOLUTIONS TO GET THE STATE
BOARD THE PORTIONS FORTY IT
NEEDS. ALSO VERY ABOUT THE
INDIOS REFUSAL TO OFFER MORE
LOCATIONS FOR THE NATIONAL
BOARD TEST. WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY ON
FINDING THE SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM. CREATED BY HAVING ONLY
ONE TESTING SITE LOCATED ALL
THE WAY ON THE EAST COAST. BUT
CAN THEY MAKE IS REALLY TAUGHT
US NEED MORE FLEXIBILITY IN A
LOCK. AS SUCH WE SUPPORT THE
BOARD HAVING ITS OWN STATE OF
EMERGENCY STATUTE ALLOWING IT
TO WAIVE PROVISIONS OF THE
OPTOMETRIC PRACTICE. THAT
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY. I
ALSO WANT TO TOUCH ON THE
CONCERNS. ABOUT THE PRACTICE
LAW. TODAY'S CALIFORNIA
COMMENTERS. ARE TRYING TO DO SO
MUCH MORE THAN THEIR PERMITTED
IN CALIFORNIA. IT JUST DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE WHY SPEND ALL THIS
MONEY EDUCATING OPTOMETRISTS
AND THEN PREVENTING THEM FROM
PRACTICING TO THE FULL EXTENT
OF THAT TRAINING. TOM AND OTHER
STATES FOR MORE MINOR SURGICAL.
INCLUDING THE USE OF LASERS TO
TRICKLE COME OUT WITH NO
PROBLEMS. THE LINE CALIFORNIA
SO SPECIFIC IT CAN'T CHANGES
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES. NO OTHER
STATE IN THE NATION WITH ALL
THE DRUGS AND THE CONDITIONS
ARE ALLOWED IN STATUTE IT IS A
PROBLEM FOR PATIENT CARE. I'LL
GIVE AN EXAMPLE WE HAVE A NEW
DRUG WHICH VERY FEW SIDE
EFFECTS THAT INDICATED TO TREAT
AN ISLAND CONDITION. COULD ONLY
PREVIOUSLY BE TREATED WITH
SURGERY BUT AN OPTOMETRIST
CAN'T USE IT BECAUSE A LOT OF
ALLOW THE TREATMENT THAT
CONDITION. CALIFORNIA DEMOCRAT
IS CONFUSING AND ANTIQUATED AND
WE NEED TO FIND ANOTHER. WAY OF
GETTING PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
TREATMENT THEY NEED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES INTO IT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY. SEEING
NONE THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
WE'RE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY. MISTER STEVE WEEKS
BOARD PRESIDENT WILL PRESENT
MISTER WEEKS IF YOU'RE WITH
ISSUE MAY PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN ROB GERMINAL SENATORS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
STEVE WEEKS OFF AND I AM A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD HOUSE
METROLOGY. PRESENTING WITH ME
TODAY IS OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER
CHRISTIAAN DOUBLE. I WAS
APPOINTED TO THE BOARD ON JULY
TWENTY EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN RIGHT AND SENATE. PRO
TEM KEVIN DE LEON AND I WAS RE
APPOINTED ON JANUARY TWENTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BY SENATE PRO
TEM TWENTY ACTS. AS A PUBLIC
MEMBER OF THE BOARD. IT'S JUST
BEEN AN ENLIGHTENING EXPERIENCE
TO LEARN FIRSTHAND THE ROLE
THAT THE BOARD PLACING
PROVIDING CONSUMER PROTECTION
TO SO MANY CALIFORNIANS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ALL HAVE
RECEIVED VERY DETAILED
BACKGROUND PAPER ON REPORTS
WHILE NOT TAKE UP THE
COMMITTEES TIME NOW WITH THE
HISTORY OF THE BOARD. I WOULD
TOUCH VERY BRIEFLY ON A FEW
POINTS THAT MAY BE OF VALUE TO
DESPAIRING. OUR BOARD ONE OF
THE LARGEST COSMETOLOGY AND
BARBERING BOARDS IN THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND LICENSEES AND TWO
HUNDRED FORTY SIX APPROVED
SCHOOLS THE NUMBERS ARE REALLY
STAGGERING WE MONITOR FIFTY
THOUSAND ESTABLISHMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE TALENTED
AND DEDICATED STAFF OF LESS
THAN ONE HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS.
SINCE OUR LAST SUNSET REVIEW
THE BORDER SEEN MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WHEN WE ARE
MOST PROUD OF IS OUR
IMPROVEMENT IN LANGUAGE ACCESS
FOR EXAMS IN OUR PUBLICATIONS
ARE OFFERED VIETNAMESE SPANISH
AND KOREAN. WE HAVE SINCE
EXPANDED TRANSLATIONS OF OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY REGULATIONS
THE FARSI ARABIC IN TRADITIONAL
AND SIMPLIFIED CHINESE. WE
CONTINUE TO EXPAND OUR OUTREACH
TO DIVERSE POPULATION IN FACT
JUST EARLIER THIS WEEK WE HELD
VIRTUAL EVENTS IN SPANISH AND
VIETNAMESE ON HOW TO STAY SAFE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
SINCE OUR LAST REVIEW OUR
BORDERS WORK WITH THE BUREAU
FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY BUT
WE WERE ABLE TO STOP FRAUDULENT
SCHOOLS THAT WERE BASICALLY
OPERATING AS DEPLOYMENT HOUSE
WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE ACTION
AGAINST THREE SCHOOLS THAT WERE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF STUDENTS
AND NOT PROVIDING THEM. THE
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE. AS YOU
KNOW THE BARB BECAUSE- INDUSTRY
HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED
BECAUSE OF THE COLD BUT
NINETEEN AND DEMI. OUR BORDER
SPENT THE LAST YEAR WORKING TO
RAISE AWARENESS OF THE PANDEMIC
AND EDUCATE LICENSEES ON HOW TO
KEEP THEMSELVES AND THEIR
CLIENTS SAFE DURING THIS
DIFFICULT UNPRECEDENTED TIMES.
WE TRANSITIONED OUR INSPECTORS
CAME FROM AN ENFORCEMENT
PERSPECTIVE TO AN EDUCATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE. WE HAVE DEVELOPED
MATERIALS DESIGNED TO HELP OUR
LICENSEES GET BACK TO WORK
SAFELY AND WE WORKED DIRECTLY
WITH MANY COUNTIES ON JOINT
VISITS TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
ON CALL THAT NINETEEN TESTING.
INDUSTRY GUIDELINES ON SAFE
PRACTICES AND INFORMATION ON
THE STATUS OF STATEWIDE
RESTRICTIONS WE WERE ALSO PART
OF THE GOVERNOR'S ENFORCEMENT
TASK FORCE WHERE WE AGAIN
PROVIDED VALUABLE EDUCATION AND
IN SOME CASES DISCIPLINE OF
LICENSEES WERE PUTTING FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS HI REST.
THE BORDERS AWARE OF THE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS TO
MINIMIZE ANY BARRIER TO ENTRY
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO PURSUING
THIS FURTHER WITH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF. OUR BOARD IS
READY TO TAKE ON THE CHALLENGES
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUALLY IMPROVE THE MANY
SERVICES WE PROVIDE. WE THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS ANY OF YOUR CONCERNS
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXTEND
OUR GRATITUDE TO THE STAFF. OF
BOTH COMMITTEES FOR THE
COMMUNICATION TO THE PROVIDED
TO OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
ARE BORED WITH THAT WE ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
WEEKS WILL OF CHRISTY UNDER
WOULD. BE PROVIDING ANY COMMENT.
NO IT DOES NOT COMMENT OKAY.
MANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMITTEES. LOW. LET ME
START OFF WITH A COUPLE AND
THEN I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUES
WILL JUMP IN IF THEY- DAVID
APPROPRIATE. I'M CURIOUS ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE CONTINUALLY
GRAPPLE WITH. IN THESE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES IS
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT AND
ACCESS AND IN READING THE-
BACKGROUND MATERIAL I WAS.
STRUCK BY OF THE COST. IF FOR
EXAMPLE A PRIVATE COLLEGE
COSMETOLOGY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR OF SIXTEEN HUNDRED
OUR COURSE AND I WAS JUST
CURIOUS. IF YOU KNOW HOW LONG
IT ON THE AVERAGE IT TAKES A
COSMETOLOGIST TO. TO RECOVER
THE COST OF THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY. WE WELL THAT ARE
EXPECTED OFFICER- ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BUT AGAIN THE COST OF
EDUCATION COSMETOLOGY EDUCATION
REALLY CAN VERY SICK CAN BE
EXPENSIVE AND SOME PRIVATE
SCHOOLS AND YET IT CAN BE
RELATIVELY INEXPENSIVE I GO
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NOW SO I'LL LET HER SPEAK TO
THAT BUT WE WILL JUST TO SET
THE STAGE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THEY'RE ONLY ABOUT TEN. OR SO
GIVE OR TAKE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS- STILL EXISTING IN THE
STATE IS THAT CORRECT. THANK
YOU THINK. SORRY WE'RE HAVING
IRAN YOU JUST HAVE TO SPEAK UP
FOR OLD PEOPLE LIKE ME. WELL
NOW ONE MAN NO I'M NOT HEARING
YOU AT ALL. MY LIP READING
SKILLS HAVE ATROPHIED. NO.
SEVEN I THINK WE'RE- WE'RE
HAVING A SOUND PROBLEM MA'AM.
WE'RE WORKING THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY. AND WE WILL WE WILL
COMPENSATE A LITTLE NOW I HAVE
NOT OUR OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICERS
COME DOWN HERE AND WE CAN
CERTAINLY SHARE THE SAME DEVICE.
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
NOW PERFECTLY. ALL WE ARE SO
SORRY FOR THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW A PERFECTLY WE EXPERIENCED
A LOT OF THE TIME DON'T WORRY
THANK YOU. I AM SO GOING BACK
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES ONE OF
THE THINGS IS I DO THINK
THERE'S MORE THAN TEN AND WE
COULD GET THOSE EXACT NUMBERS
AND YOU KNOW THEY THEY ARE NOT
AS MANY AS WE WOULD HOPE TO SEE
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUT I
DO THINK I AM VERY IT'S A GREAT
PROGRAM THAT THEY HAVE IN THOSE
IN THOSE LOCATIONS. AND I THINK
IT'S YOU KNOW THEY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT ARE IN
EFFECT. LARGE AND ENROLLMENT.
AND SO IT IT DEFINITELY IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD LOVE TO
SEE IF MORE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WOULD TAKE TAKE THAT ON. AND
THEN I'M GOING BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT THE COST OF THE
OF THE- DAY EDUCATION AND HOW
THEY- RECOVERED THAT AFTER
THEIR LICENSE. IT REALLY M. WE
DON'T AND WE DON'T REALLY TRACK
EMPLOYMENT OF OUR LICENSEES SO
WELL THEY THEY DO GET A LICENSE
AND THEN AND- THAT'S KIND OF IT
FOR WHERE WHERE WHERE WE OTHER
THAN ENFORCEMENT OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY. AND SO WE HAVEN'T
REALLY EVER STUDIED BE INCOME
ASPECT AFTER LICENSURE AND- WE
DON'T WE DON'T MAINTAIN ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STUDENTS
WHEN THEY'RE IN CHOOL AND HOW
THEY HOW THEY ATTENDED SCHOOL
IF THEY'VE GONE THROUGH. AND A
STUDENT AID PROGRAM OR NOT AND
SO WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATA AND
IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING WE COULD
WORK WITH THE BUREAU PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY TO OBTAIN NOW.
WHAT THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL I'M
CERTAINLY GOING TO FOLLOW UP
WITH THE BUREAU AS WELL BECAUSE
IT'S AND IT'S AN ISSUE AN
INTEREST AREA FOR. ME
PERSONALLY- TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT FOR PUTTING TRAINING
PROGRAMS OUT THERE THAT HE
TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY
TRAINING PEOPLE FOR JOBS. FOR
GOOD PAYING JOBS THAT ACTUALLY
EXIST AND THAT WERE NOT SIMPLY
RACKING UP EDUCATIONAL DEBT FOR
WHICH INDIVIDUALS EITHER CANNOT
PAY OR SPEND CONSIDERABLE
PERIODS OF TIME TRYING TO PAY
OFF- IN THE FUTURE LET ME THEN
SHIFT TO. OF THE REQUIRED HOURS
OF INSTRUCTION- THE NECESSARY
TO SECURE- OF WHAT LICENSURE-
AND- AND ULTIMATELY POSITIONS
IN THE BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY FIELD IN THE STATE-
BUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS
REQUIRED FOR COSMETOLOGY.
OTHERS SOME APPRENTICESHIP I
GUESS ISSUES BUT THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS FOR BARBERING.
HOW WERE THOSE REQUIREMENTS SET
I NOTICED THAT THE HOURS ARE-
EVEN IN NUMBER- WHICH IS
SOMEWHAT UNUSUAL I THINK IN THE
EDUCATIONAL AREA. CAN SOMEONE
ADDRESS THAT FOR ME. SURE I AM
I THINK THE HOURS HAVE BEEN SET
MANY MANY YEARS AGO M. SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS IS WHAT WE HAVE
FOR. COSMETOLOGY RIGHT NOW
AND I THINK THAT'S BEEN IN
EFFECT FOR. QUITE SOME TIME AND
I'VE PERSONALLY BEEN AT THE
BOARD FOR SIXTEEN YEARS AND I
KNOW IT WAS. THAT AND LONG
BEFORE I ATTENDED AND- SO YOU
KNOW HOW IT WAS ORIGINALLY
THOUGHT OF BACK IN THE
BEGINNING I'M NOT POSITIVE AND-
WE HAVE DONE SOME CURRICULUM
REVIEW OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS BUT THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS HAS. HAS REMAINED AND
BEEN. FOR MANY YEARS IT'S BEEN
PRETTY CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY AND THERE'S BEEN.
LOTS OF BRICK AND CHANGES OVER
AND YEARS IN VARIOUS STATE. I
AM WHICH I BELIEVE YOU KNOW IS
NOTED IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER
AND- SO AND- YOU KNOW IT'S-
CLOSE IN STATE THE- THE
MAJORITY OF STATES RIGHT NOW-
RIGHT AT FIFTEEN HUNDRED. M.
AND THERE'S YOU KNOW A FEW
STATES THAT ARE- EVEN OVER AND
SIXTEEN HUNDRED. SO IT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT- HAS
BEEN IN PLACE. IN THIS-
INDUSTRY. FOR JUST A NUMBER OF
YEARS. WELL I MEAN LOOKING AT
THE- I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
I'M COMPARING OCCUPATIONS
APPLES TO APPLES HERE BUT- IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT COSMETOLOGY
AND IF I'VE GOT THE RIGHT
INFORMATION LOOKING AT THE
BACKGROUND. PAPER IT INDICATES
THAT VERMONT IN TEXAS ARE NOW
TO THOUSAND HOURS. IN RHODE
ISLAND WENT FROM FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS TO SIX HUNDRED
HOURS. IN VARIOUS MMHM. THE NEW
YORK HAS A LOWER REQUIREMENT
THAN WE DO AND THAT SORT OF
UNUSUAL SO I'M I'M I'M JUST
CURIOUS AS TO WHAT SORT OF A
REGULAR WE'VE APPLIED TO MAKING
SURE THAT THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED FOR THESE
OCCUPATIONS BARBERING
COSMETOLOGY IN THE VARIOUS
CATEGORIES THAT FALL. VETERANS
SOCIAIS DID WITH THOSE. THAT
THE REQUIREMENTS ARE CURRENT.
AND THAT THE REQUIREMENTS ARE
ABSOLUTE REQUIREMENTS AS
OPPOSED TO. CONDITIONS THAT
SOMEONE JUST WANTS TO IMPOSE
CAN YOU CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT
FOR ME. ABSOLUTELY I THINK THAT
AND WE KNOW TEXAS MAKE THE
CHANGE FROM FROM SIXTEEN
HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND AND AS
YOU MENTIONED NEW YORK SENATE
THOUSAND FOR QUITE SOME TIME
AND SO I DEFINITELY THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT OUR OUR BOARD
MEETS CHIU M. NEEDS TO LOOK AT
THEM THE TIMES HAVE CHANGED AND
I THINK- WE ARE YOU KNOW WE ARE
MORE THAN WILLING WE KNOW THIS
IS A NATIONAL DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING AS WELL. AND
I DEFINITELY THINK BARBARA
COURTS PREPARED TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEES TO DETERMINE AND
IF THE HOURS SHOULD BE REDUCED
TO M. TO ALLOW BETTER ENTRY
INTO THE INTO THE INDUSTRY. I
WAS TAKEN BY THE FACT THAT
THERE'S ONLY A ONE HUNDRED HOUR
DIFFERENCE IN TRAINING REQUIRED
FOR BARBERS AS OPPOSED TO
COSMETOLOGISTS AND WHILE I'M BY
AS I UNDERSTAND WHEN I READ THE
OCCUPATIONAL DESCRIPTIONS
BERBERS CAN BARBERING CERTAINLY
INVOLVES HER COLORING. IN THE
LAKE. BUT MY- PROBABLY ON. PINE
CERTAINLY NON PROFESSIONAL A
VIEW OF IT IS COSMETOLOGY
INVOLVES MUCH MORE. THAT COULD
INVOLVE MUCH MORE TECHNICAL
ASPECTS HAVING TO DO WITH HAIR
COLORING AND OTHER SORTS OF
TECHNIQUES THAT CHEMICAL USE
THAT. YOU MIGHT NOT SEE IT A
TYPICAL BARBER SHOP. AM I AM
TAKEN BY THE FACT THAT THERE'S
ONLY A ONE HUNDRED HOUR
DIFFERENCE IN THE TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS CAN SOMEONE
ADDRESS THAT FOR ME. SURE THAT
THAT'S CORRECT THERE'S ONLY ONE
HUNDRED HOURS A COSMETOLOGIST
IS TRAINED TO M. NOT ONLY DO
CARE SERVICES BUT ALSO DO SKIN
AND NAIL SERVICES AND SO THE
COSMETOLOGY LICENSES IT'S AN
INSTANCE OF A MASTER LICENSE
AND A SENSE THAT IT. AND
HOWEVER AS THOSE AREAS
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE BARBER%
IS AND THEY PUT ON THEIR MORE
COMMON TO SHAPE THEM AND
PROVIDE AND THE SHAVINGS OF AND
STEP HERE FOR THE BEARD AND SO.
THE ONE HUNDRED HOURS AND WHY
IT IS THAT DIFFERENCE- A BARBER
CANNOT USE INTERNALS BUT AND
DOES IT HAVE THE ADDED
EDUCATION FOR THE SHAPING
ASPECTS SO- AGAIN IT'S ANOTHER
TREND AS WELL THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY THAT
THIS NEEDS TO BE- LOOKED AT AND
I AM I DEFINITELY THINK OUR
BOARD IS IN THE POSITION NOW
TO. AND TO MAKE YOU KNOW SO TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEES TO
MAKE SOME CHANGES WELL
OBVIOUSLY I DON'T KNOW WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES THINK ABOUT THIS BUT
OBVIOUSLY THIS ISN'T. AN ISSUE
OF CONCERN TO ME BECAUSE IT MAY
VERY WELL BE THAT FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS FOR BARBER
BARBERS AND SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS FOR COSMETOLOGIST UPON
REVIEW APPEARS TO BE
APPROPRIATE I WILL NOTE IF IN
FACT IT'S ACCURATE THAT AND I
HAVE NO PROBLEM BY THE WAY WITH
HEALTH AND SAFETY INSTRUCTION.
INSTRUCTION. ON BACTERIOLOGICAL
BACK. OLOGY AND SIGNET SUBJECT
LIKE THE- I'M NOT WITH THAT
BEING INCLUDED BUT THE
BACKGROUND PAPERS SEEM TO
SUGGEST THAT THAT TOTAL
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWENTY AND
THIRTY HOURS OF THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED OR SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS INVOLVED. SO I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU YOU BEGIN THE PROCESS
RATHER QUICKLY. TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE IMPOSE. FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SECURE LICENSURE IN THE
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY AREA
HOWEVER THAT'S BROKEN DOWN. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE ARE
REQUIRING IS A STATE IS IN FACT
NOT A BARRIER TO EMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE FOR MANY PEOPLE. THIS
IS AN ENTRY LEVEL OCCUPATION AN
OCCUPATION WHERE ONCE THEY
SECURE. A LICENSE. CAN BE A
MEANS TO PROVIDE A LIVING FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND IF WE'RE PUTTING OBSTACLES
IN FRONT OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
IF WE ARE. IMPOSING AT
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
CARRY A COST THAT'S DIFFICULT
TO PAY BACK. THAT IS COMPLETELY
CONTRARY CERTAINLY TO WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN AND I
SUSPECT IF WE AS MY COLLEAGUES
IN THIS CHAMBER AND THOSE WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
MANY OF THEM IF NOT MOST OR ALL
OF THE MAY AGREE SO I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS I PLAN TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE STUDY THAT
WAS DONE. APPARENTLY SOME TIME
AGO TO SUPPORT THERETENTION OF
THE FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
HUNDRED OUR- A REQUIREMENT TO
SEE HOW RIGOROUS. PROCEDURES
THAT- THAT WENT OUT OF VOGUE IN
NINETEEN FORTY YEAR IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE- THE FIRST TRAINING
ON CHEMICALS THAT THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN USED OR IN FACT MAY BE
PROHIBITED. FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS AND WE NEED TO REVISE OUR
TRAINING PROGRAM SO I'M
CONFIDENT THAT YOU AND THE
BOARD WILL DO THAT. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
BECAUSE- IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
TRAINING IS NOT ALL HEALTH AND
SAFETY RELATED. AND IT'S
PROBABLY CLEAR THE- BARBERING
AND COSMETOLOGY IS NOT ANY LESS
SAFE IN VERMONT TEXAS- ROME
ROAD ISLAND OR NEW YORK THAN IT
IS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE CERTAINLY DON'T WE DON'T
WANT IT TO BE ANY LESS SAFE
YEARS SO I AM GOING TO STOP MY
REMARKS AT THIS TIME AND JUST
GO BACK TO THE- RIGHT PLACE TO
MENTION ONE THING THAT. I THINK
UP TO LOOK AT THIS ALSO WE'RE
WE'RE IN AGREEMENT WITH YOU ON
THAT COMPLETELY AND THE BOARD
IS CONCEPTUALLY PRE APPROVED
RECENTLY THE MOVING TO A HAIR
STYLIST ONLY LICENSED. AND
IT'S- SHOWING THAT WHEN WE
MOVED TO THAT AREA WE CAN CUT
DOWN THE AMOUNT OF EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS IF THEY'RE ONLY
INVOLVEMENT AS METROLOGY
PERSPECTIVE FROM MATT
HAIRSTYLIST SONG SO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR ALTERNATIVES LIKE
YOU ARE IN THIS AREA THAT COULD
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE IN
OUR PROFESSION. AND UP WITH A
LOT MORE LIMITED AMOUNT OF
MONEY. THANK YOU BECAUSE WHAT I
DIDN'T SAY BUT I HOPE WAS
IMPLICIT IN MY COMMENTS IS AND
FRANKLY IN SOME AREAS PERHAPS
NOT THIS ONE I THINK WE OVER
LICENSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE SHOULD LEAN.
AWAY FROM THE WERE PUT. AND
CERTAINLY WHERE WE- MAKE SURE
THAT THE TRAINING IN THE
LICENSURE IS LIMITED INC AND
THEN TARGETED. TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND PROFICIENCY- AND
CERTAINLY NOTHING ELSE. HAVING
SAID THAT I SEE SEARCH A LETTER
WELL THIS YEAR I JUST WANT TO
COMPLIMENT YOU ON BRING IN
THESE THESE ITEMS UP BECAUSE I
THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THE COMMITTEE IS LOOKING AT
THAT AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
SCHOOLS. PRIVATE SCHOOLS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THE MECHANICS ELECTRONICS
WHATEVER IT IS IN THE BIG
QUESTION A WE ALWAYS HAVE IS
THE SCHOOL PROVIDED THE
EDUCATION THAT EQUIVALENT TO
THE PAY AT THE OTHER END. WHERE
WE FIND STUDENTS THAT ARE ARE
WITH DEBT THAT THE JOB IS THEIR
PAY AND- EIGHT NINE TEN DOLLARS
AN HOUR VERSUS THE COST OF
HAVING A THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
DEBT REMAINING IN THE SCHOOL SO
THAT'S THE- AND ANGLE THAT THAT
WE'VE GOT TO LOOK AT AND I'M
HOPING THAT THE BOARD WILL LOOK
AT THAT- THE MEANS. THAT SHOULD
JUSTIFY THE ENDS SO
CONSEQUENTLY YOUR COMMENTS ARE
RIGHT ON AND I THANK YOU FOR
THAT BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
YES SOME OF THESE JOBS ARE
ENTRY LEVEL SOME OF THE- THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THESE
FIELDS- GO OUT TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY REALLY
NEED HELP. AND B. AND IF THE
COST IS PROHIBITIVE IN THE
INCOME IS NOT THERE THEN WE'VE
GOT TO TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT IT
AND IN KEEPING IN MIND OF
COURSE HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
PROTECTING THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
SO LOOKING AT THE CURRICULUM
MIGHT BE ABLE SOME WE MIGHT
FIND SOME ADJUSTMENTS THERE TO
OFFSET THE COST THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER CARILLO PLEASE. TAKE
IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT CHAIR
ROTH AND CENTER DR LET I WOULD
YOU WANT TO REAFFIRM- THE
COMMENTS THAT. OU MADE- YOU
COULD HAVE SAID IT ANY MORE.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE CONCERNS
SPECIFICALLY ON OVER REGULATION
AND LICENSURE OF A COMMENSURATE
WITH THE DATA THAT WE'VE SEEN I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT-
ACCORDING TO UCLA'S OF
CALIFORNIA. HEALTHY NAIL SALON
COLLABORATIVE. AND IF- OF OUR
MAKE LESS THAN SIX DOLLARS A
WEEK A MAJORITY OF INDIVIDUALS
ARE. EARNING LESS THAN SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS A WEEK- IN THIS
IN THIS CATEGORY AND THAT'S
ALARMING AND THAT. JUST SHOWS
THAT THE TO THE POVERTY LEVEL
WAGES AND- WHAT'S PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING ALSO IS- DAY-
PERCENTAGE OF NAIL SALON
WORKERS. THAT ARE CONSISTING OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY MANY OF THEM WOMEN IN
FACT I UNDERSTAND THAT A CO
CLOSE TO EIGHTY ONE PERCENT.
ARE WOMEN WITH RESPECT TO NAIL
SALON WORKERS AND FOR THE ONLY
ABOUT HALF OF THE WORKERS ARE
CONSIDERED. ENGLISH PROFICIENT.
SO WITH ALL OF THESE ISSUES
WITH RESPECT TO EVEN HATE AND
ALL OF THESE. OUTSTANDING
ISSUES THE QUESTION THEN IS
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF OVER REGULATION AS WELL AS
THEY COVERED PANDEMIC ON THE
INDUSTRY- IN MOST CASES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ASIAN WOMEN MANY
OF THEM IMMIGRANTS OR REFUGEES.
AND SO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF HOW
MANY LICENSEES ARE. IDENTIFIES
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW IDEAL AND
YOU KNOW WE DON'T COLLECT THAT
INFORMATION. BUT I'VE BEEN I'VE
BEEN WITH THE BOARD FOR SIXTEEN
PLUS YEARS AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THAT THAT NUMBER THAT YOU
MENTIONED JUST PROBABLY HIGHER.
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE CLOSE TO
THEM A HUNDRED THOUSAND
LICENSED MANICURISTS IN THE
STATE. M. AND I WOULD I WOULD
VENTURE THAT THE PERCENTAGE
THAT ARE. OF ASIAN DESCENT IS
HIGHER THAN THAT M. 80% IT
WOULD PROBABLY AND PUT IT MORE
IN THE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
PERCENT. AND SO IT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE TRIED TO
INCREASE OUR OUTREACH M. TO THE
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
COMMUNITIES M. WE'RE FORTUNATE
IT AND WE HAVE HAD SOME GREAT
SUCCESS WITH THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY. AND WE'VE HAD SOME
GREAT PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE HAVE
BUILT IN ORDER TO AND GET
INFORMATION OUT AND IN IN
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES SO. AND WE
WHAT WE DO SO WE DON'T HAVE
THAT EXACT DATA BUT BUT MY
SENSES WE DO HAVE A VERY HIGH
POPULATION. OF AND THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND COMMUNITY
IN THIS INDUSTRY NOT ONLY IN
OUR MANICURIST LICENSING BUT
ALSO IN OUR AND- I'M SO SORRY
MY POWER. WE HAVE AN ALL KINDS
OF TECHNICAL THINGS TODAY I'M
SORRY- BUT ALSO AS WELL AS OUR
INSTITUTION WITH THEIR SKIN
CARE COMMUNITY M. AND SO IT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
PUT AT THE TOP OF OUR LIST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
COMMUNICATING WITH THIS- WITH
THESE WORKERS AND MAKING SURE
THAT THY'RE SAFE AS WELL AS-
IN THEIR CLIENT STATES AND I
THINK WE'VE- WE'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL. IN. IN OUR
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THIS AREA.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE GALLON
THAT IN THE NUMBERS MIGHT BE
HIGHER ABOUT NINETY PER. OF
CONSISTENT ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER WOMEN AND AGAIN YOU
CAN SEE THE VICTIMIZATION
CLEARLY AND A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AREAS OR EVEN TO THE
ISSUES OF LANGUAGE ACCESS. AS
YOU KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
LOOK AT DISAGGREGATED DATA TO
BEST UNDERSTAND POLICY AND IF
WE DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFICS
AROUND DATA AND DEMOGRAPHICS IT
BECOMES CHALLENGING. FOR US TO
DO SO I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
WELCOME AND BE OPEN TO THAT OF
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN.
CAN I SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
EVEN FOR THE ISSUES OF
EXAMINATIONS THAT OFFER IN
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH
HAVE YOU OBSERVED ANY MAJOR
DIFFERENCES IN PASSAGE RATES.
WE HAVE THEM YOU KNOW ARE WE
GIVE OUR EXAMS IN ENGLISH AND
IN SPANISH AND VIETNAMESE AND
KOREAN AT THAT THE VIETNAMESE
AND THE CURRY AND PASS RATES
USUALLY ARE VERY- ARE ARE
USUALLY HIGHER THAN THE REST
AND THE SPANISH PASS RATES
REMAINS A CONCERN. FOR OUR
BOARD AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT FOR. MANY
MANY YEARS AND- I'LL ACTUALLY
CARRIED OVER TO MY PORT NUMBER.
YES YOU'RE RIGHT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE SPANISH FAST
RATES ARE ON OUR WRITTEN EXAM
FOR A VERY LONG TIME. AND THE
BOARDS TRY TO DO EVERY TYPE OF
ANALYTICS THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
WE TALKED TO- R. AS WE TALK TO
OUR SCHOOLS WE TALKED TO THE
STATE OUR- EDUCATIONAL PEOPLE-
IN CALIFORNIA TO DETERMINISTIC
TESTING PROPER ALL THE
PROTOCOLS BEING MET. WE TALK
WITH OUR NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
ARE WHO ACTUALLY RUNS AND
MONITORS THE EXAMINATION WHAT
THEIR THOUGHTS WERE WE EVEN
BROUGHT IN A COUPLE TECHNICAL
PEOPLE THAT THAT ARE- STAFF
STAFF THEIR AGENCY. TO TALK TO
OUR PORTS AND- WE WILL REALLY
COULDN'T FIND A REAL. THERE
WERE STILL TO FIND WHY THE
SPANISH- THE FAILURE RATES WERE
SO HIGH BUT IN LOOKING AT
ANOTHER ASPECT. OF SPECIFICALLY
OUR PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM THAT
WE'RE WORKING WITH WE REVIEWED.
OUR APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING AND
FOUND IT TO BE. PRETTY
INADEQUATE IN A LOT OF AREAS
ARE THERE RECEIVING TRAINING
FOR ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY HOURS AND THE REST THEIR
TIME THEY'RE WORKING AND THE
ACTUAL SHOPS AND- WHICH THEY DO
FOR TWO YEARS. BUT THEY HAVE TO
PASS THE WRITTEN EXAMINATION AT
THE END OF THIS AREA. AND THEIR
EXAMINATION REYES DISAPPEARS
FROM ALL THE PASS RATE IS ONLY
IN THE LOW THIRTIES WILL ROLL
IN THE PACIFIC AND THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM SO THIS
LEADS WE BELIEVE TO OUR LOW
STATEWIDE PASS RATE IN THIS
AREA. SO WE THOUGHT BY
ATTACKING A PROBLEMS THAT WE
SAW IN THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM WOULD ALSO HELP RESOLVE
OUR LOW PASS RATES ON SPANISH
LANGUAGE TESTING. SO OUR BOARD
IS REALLY JUST RECENTLY BROUGHT
FORTH AND APPROVE OTTE'S FIFTY
DIFFERENT RECOMMENDED CHANGES
TO THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
THAT WOULD BETTER AMPLIFY OUR
NEEDS AND THEIR NEEDS FOR
PASSING THIS WRITTEN
EXAMINATION AND WE'RE WORKING
ON. THAT- DILIGENTLY RIGHT NOW.
OKAY THEY GIVE VERY MUCH. ALSO
WHICH WAS REFER THE AGAIN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL SALON
COLLABORATIVE- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE CURRENT CLIMATE POST CODE-
BUT ALSO RULING WITH RESPECT TO
THAT EIGHT THE XENA PHOBIA
STEREOTYPING AND DISCRIMINATION
THE FIRST RECOMMENDATION WAS
PROVIDING. A TRANSLATED TO
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH AND SAFETY
GUIDELINES FOR BUSINESSES TO
SUPPORT THEM IN THE RE OPENING
AND THEN SECONDLY COORDINATING
AN ISSUE CAMPAIGN TO COUNTER
XENOPHOBIA STEREOTYPING
DISCRIMINATION AND VIOLENCE
AND- THE NAIL SALONS AND THEN
THIRDLY TO ENSURE ENSURE THAT
STRONG WORKER PROTECTIONS ARE
IN PLACE IN THE CONTEXT OF RE
OPENING HAS THAT SOMETHING ARE
THESE MEASURES ON FRONT AND
CENTER. AS WELL ON YOUR WRITER.
ABSOLUTELY AND WE'RE MORE THAN
WILLING TO WORK WITH AND THE
COLLABORATIVE AS WELL AS AND
ANYONE FROM THE API CAUCUS AND
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S DEFINITELY A
CONCERN OF OURS. WE DEAL WITH
SUCH A LARGE VOLUME AND HAVE
ACCESS TO SO MANY- LICENSEES
THAT ARE AND THAT AND- YOU KNOW
THE API AREA AND SO I
DEFINITELY THINK. THERE'S A LOT
WE COULD DO TO ADD FACILITATE
BETTER EDUCATION- WE WOULD
WELCOME ANY TYPE OF
PARTNERSHIPS IN IN THAT AREA.
M. AND T. IN THE IN THE
FOREFRONT AND BECAUSE WE HAVE
SUCH ACCESS TO YOU AND SO MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND I THINK IT'S
WHERE WE STARTED WITH THEM
HOLDING OUR OWN AND VIRTUAL
EVENTS- AS MR WEEKES MENTIONED
IN HIS OPENING STATEMENT. JUST
HELD ON ON TUESDAY AND EVENT
FOR OUR VIETNAMESE LICENSEES
I'M WITH OUR VIETNAMESE STAFF
SO THE VIRTUAL EVENT WHAT WAS
DONE IN IN THAT LANGUAGE AND WE
WERE ABLE TO HELP THEM ANSWER.
QUESTIONS AND GIVE IT QUEUE IN
A WHICH AND WE HOPE IS I'M
GOING TO BE HELPFUL AND WE ARE
LOOKING TO DO MORE OF THAT TYPE
OF WORK AND IN THE FUTURE AND-
WE HAVE TRANSLATED ALL OF OUR
INFORMATION AND FROM OUR BOARD
AND WE HAVE OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY REGULATIONS TRANSLATED
AGAIN. M. ENGLISH VIETNAMESE
SPANISH AND- CREAN BUT WE'VE
ALSO ADDED PERCY ARABIC AND-
SIMPLIFIED INTERESTED
TRADITIONAL CHINESE JUST SO WE
CAN TRY TO REACH M. AS MANY OF
OUR LICENSEES AS POSSIBLE WE'RE
LOOKING EVEN AT FURTHER
LANGUAGES AND THAT FOR OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY REGULATIONS
WHICH IS. HOW THEY SHOULD BE
OPERATING IN THEIR IN THEIR
SALON SO WE'RE REALLY LOOKING.
TO TRY TO MAKE THAT AVAILABLE
NâNG. GREAT THEN- JUST OF THE
LAST IS COMMON FOR CLAY FOR. IT
WOULD YOU AGREE WITH THAT AS IN
THIS IS THAT THE AVERAGE WE- IS
SIX HUNDRED. A WEEK FOR A
WORKER OF LICENSING AND NAIL
SALON. M. I. A. I AM NOT I
WOULDN'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
ON THAT AT ALL IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE'VE EVER COLLECTED
DATA ON IT ALSO I ACTUALLY
DON'T I'M NOT SURE ABOUT THAT.
I'M SORRY YOU DON'T HAVE DATA
ON THE AVERAGE WAGE FOR A
LICENSEE IN A NAIL SALON. WE DO
NOT. DID YOU DO YOU HAVE. DATA
OR STATISTICS AS TO THE AVERAGE
WAGE FOR THE LICENSEES IN
GENERAL. WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF
THE OF THE WAGE STATISTICS I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE COULD
PROBABLY GAIN FOR YOU FROM FROM
OTHER AGENCIES BUT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT ARTWORK OKAY
SOMETHING THAT THE BOARD
COLLECTS BUT DOES THAT SOUND
REASONABLE IF OF THAT THE
PACKETS OF INFORMATION FROM THE
UCLA LA LABOR CENTER- SHOWS
THAT APPROXIMATELY THAT'S THE
AVERAGE AMOUNT. COMES OUT TO
THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
ABOUT RIGHT YES OKAY SO THIRTY
WITH THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR A LICENSEE-
AND THEN BE A TO THE
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS IF THE
AVERAGE COSTS ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS AT A
PRIVATE SCHOOL. CRITICS FIVE I
JUST. BUT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THAT THIS DOESN'T SETTLE WELL
WITH ME OR I THINK ANYONE
FRANKLY- THAT THAT IT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE. AND SO. IF
I SEE YOU SHAKING YOUR HEAD.
DID DOES THIS RISE TO THE LEVEL
OF SENSE OF URGENCY
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THERE ARE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WORKING
HARD WORKING SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE PUTTING FOOD ON
THE TABLE AND YET THEY STILL
CANNOT ATTEND THE CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN DREAM. JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE DOES THIS RISE TO
THE LEVEL OF URGENCY FOR THIS
SUBSTANTIVE REFORMS IN THIS
AREA. UPSIDE I THINK IT
ABSOLUTELY RISES TO THE LEVEL
OF URGENCY. MY PHONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU TO OUR
LOW- FIRST ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU AND- I I'M
JUST GONNA BE REPEATING WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID. THIS IS THIS
REALLY IS ABOUT OVER
REGULATION- AND WE REALLY NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
SUCH HIGH BARRIERS TO ENTRY
FOR. JOBS THAT- THAT DON'T NEED
IT IN A BIT DAY EXAMPLE I WOULD
GIVE IS- DRYING SALONS WHY
WOULD THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH-
TRAINING IN HAIR DYING AND
FACIALS AND NAILS AND IT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE HAPPEN
OVERALL LICENSE LIKE THAT AND I
THINK YOU REALLY DO NEED TO
LOOK AT HEARING. BUT SO I JUST
WANT TO ADD MY VOICE TO THAT
CHORUS BUT- I WANTED TO KNOW
ALSO AND- WHAT YOU'RE DOING
ABOUT THIS EVOLVING NATURE OF
WORK- A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SEEKING A BEAUTIFICATION
OUTSIDE OF BRICK WALLS THE-
BRICK AND MORTAR OPERATIONS.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WANT- STYLISTS
COME INTO THEIR HAIR FOR
WEDDINGS AND- I. UNDERSTAND
THAT IT REQUIRES A PERSONAL
SERVICES PERMIT. AND THAT THE
BOARD WAS TASKED TO ESTABLISH
IT. TO START TO LOOK AT WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO ESTABLISH IT IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. SO JUST WANT TO
KNOW WHAT THE PROGRESS ON THAT.
BECAUSE OF I THINK THIS IS A
VERY. IMPORTANT FOR ME TO GET
IN PLACE. THANK YOU YES WE'VE
WE'VE WORKED FOR QUITE SOME
TIME ON OUR PERSONAL SERVICE
PERMIT AND THAT REGULATION
PACKAGE HAS BEEN FILED WITH THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW.
THEY HAD SOME MODIFICATIONS TO
IT AND SO WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF. FINALIZING THAT THERE AND
CHANGES TO IT M. AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THOSE SHOULD BE
APPROVED I WOULD I AM LEAVE
WTHIN THE NEXT TWO MONTHS. AND
THEN WE WILL BE READY TO GO WE
ALREADY WORK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO M. START.
THE PREPARATIONS TO IMPLEMENT
THAT SO THAT AS SOON AS OUR
REGULATIONS ARE FINALLY
APPROVED WE'RE READY TO GO AND
START ISSUING THOSE LICENSES.
SO HOW MUCH WOULD SOMETHING
LIKE THAT COST BECAUSE YOU'RE
YOU'RE KIND OF YOU'RE GONNA END
UP. IN A SITUATION THAT IT IS
THERE'S A REALLY HIGH BARRIER
TO ATTAINING THIS- THIS PERMIT
THAT PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO
APPLY FOR IT AND JUST GO AHEAD
WITH STILL DOING THERE AT. NO
THERE. PLYING THEIR TRADE
OUTSIDE OF THESE BRICK MORTAR
OPERATIONS THIS CAN BE A
REASONABLE PERMIT TO OBTAIN I
BELIEVE IT'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN I
PROGRAM TWENTY DOLLAR FEE FOR
THAT THAT LICENSE OKAY GREAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THOSE OF THOSE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS CENTER CHILLA YES
I THANK YOU MR I'D LIKE TO GET
BACK TO THE- THE PASSING RATE-
WE JUST HEARD THAT THE- THOSE
WHO DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH- TO THE
DEGREE THAT- I GUESS MOST OF US
DO BUT- HAVE DIFFICULTY IN AND
PASSED IN THE FINAL EXAM AND SO
CONSEQUENTLY THE MONEY THAT.
THEY PUT ON THE TABLE FOR THE
NUMBER OF HOURS THEY WENT THAT
THE PERHAPS THE SCHOOLS WEREN'T
GIVING THEM THE TUTORING
BRINGING IN BILINGUAL EDUCATION
PER SE. IN IN SOME WAY
PREPARING THE STUDENTS TO
SUCCEED RATHER THAN JUST TO
HAVE THESE SCHOOLS- TAKE IN THE
TUITION MONEY AND NOT LOOK AT
THE AT THE END RESULT. AS THE
CULTURE I JUST MENTIONED THAT
AGAIN THE IS THE MEANS MAY NOT
JUSTIFY THE AND AS I SAID
EARLIER FINANCIALLY. AND SO IF
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE SCHOOLS
THERE AND IN THE NUMBER OF
HOURS REQUIRED THAT I THINK
THEY SHOULD ALSO LOOK INTO
HAVING- INSTRUCTORS THAT ARE
PROFICIENT IN BOTH LANGUAGES OR
WHATEVER LANGUAGE YOU MIGHT BE.
TO HELP THE STUDENTS TO PASS IF
THEY COULD JUST LOOK INTO THAT
AND- PERHAPS- IMPLEMENTED PLAN-
THAT WOULD HELP BECAUSE SO MANY
OF THE STUDENTS BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A PASSING RATE.
THAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE FOR THE
COST THAT THEY THEY'VE THEY PUT
ON THE TABLE. THE AND I THINK
THAT'S A SUGGESTION I'D LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY TAKE A LOOK
AT. AND THEN THE OTHER THING IS
DATA WE THE CULTURED MENTION
DATA AND INFORMATION WITH SO
MANY OTHER SCHOOLS I'D MENTION
THEY HAVE THAT DATA IN IT JUST
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF RESEARCH.
RECOMMENDATION I'D LIKE TO HAVE
THEM TAKE A GOOD STRONG LOOK AT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR CHOI VOTE. CENTER YOU
ARE ON. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO-
JEFF DRESS- AT. MY COLLEAGUES
AND OUR WITNESSES HERE TODAY
JUST A QUICK QUESTION- IN LIGHT
OF THE CURRENT ENVIRONMENT THAT
WE FIND OURSELVES WITH THE-
ECONOMIC SETBACKS WE CHAT WITH
COLBERT NINETEEN- IT MOVING
FORWARD OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
HOW LONG WOULD IT TAKE OR WHAT
IS THE TIME FRAME THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT AT WITH REGARDS TO
THE STREAMLINING AB- DEBILITY
TO RECEIVE THESE LICENSES AND-
BE HAVING PEOPLE BE ABLE. TO
WORK AND- AND TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR THEMSELVES. IT
THANK YOU AND DO YOU DO YOU
MEAN PEOPLE THAT HAVE ALREADY
GONE TO SCHOOL. I'M REFERRING
TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF SIXTEEN
HOURS PER HAS BEEN RECONSIDERED
TO- A LESSER AMOUNT OF HOURS.
EXCELLENT SO. GO AHEAD PLEASE
SO IT WOULD IT WOULD OBVIOUSLY
WE WOULDN'T WE WOULD NEED THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY AND TO MAKE
THAT CHANGE. AND I'M SORRY I'M
A FRESHMAN SENATOR WOULD YOU
MIND EXPLAINING EXACTLY WHAT
THAT MEANS AND WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE. SURE SO ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU KNOW WITH WITH THAT WITH
THE SENSE THAT PROCESS I THINK
THAT'S- SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
BOTH THE COMMITTEES AND GETTING
THAT LANGUAGE. I AM SHOULD
THERE BE IT A REDUCTION IN THE
IN THE NUMBER OF HOURS WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT THROUGH
THAT THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS IN THE BILL. AND AS A
RESULT OF THIS HEARING AND THEN
MOVE FORWARD FROM THERE AND
THEN HE WOULD BE LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW POSSIBLY JANUARY. OF NEXT
YEAR FOR AN IMPLEMENTATION M.
OF COURSE THERE WILL BE A LOT
AND SHOULD THE HOURS BE REDUCED
THAT WOULD BE AND YOU KNOW A
PROCESS WE WOULD HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH WITH SCHOOLS. AND TO
DETERMINE HOW THAT COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED IN WHERE STUDENTS
ARE. THAT THE BY READING
COSMETOLOGY SCHOOLS AM.
TRADITIONALLY RAN ALL THE TIME
SO WE IN OUR BOARD WE DON'T
HAVE. A CERTAIN TIME OF YEAR
WHERE WE SEE A LOT OF
GRADUATION DATE THE GRADUATIONS
HAPPEN ALL THE TIME BECAUSE
ENROLLMENT IS FAIRLY CONTINUOUS
SO. AND IT WOULD JUST TAKE THEM
SOME FINESSE IT WORKING WITH
THE SCHOOLS TO DETERMINE HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THAT BUT WE WOULD
DEFINITELY START THIS PROCESS
AND IN WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEES AND THE STAFF TO
DETERMINE. WHAT THOSE HOURS
SHOULD BE SHOULD. THERE END UP
BEING A REDUCTION. THANK YOU
AND WOULD YOU MIND ADAM. JUST
BEING GOING A LITTLE FURTHER IN
CLARIFICATION AS FAR AS WHICH
COMMITTEES YOU'RE REFERRING TO
WOULD BEINVOLVED IN THE AN
INTERESTING THIS TOPIC. WE
WOULD WORK WITH THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AS
WELL AS THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS. OKAY AND THEN WE
HAVE TO GO THROUGH STATUTES IN
ORDER IS A BIT PASS A BILL
BASICALLY TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
CORRECT. OKAY WONDERFUL- THANK
YOU THAT'S ALL FOR ME. THANK
YOU. I DO I THOUGHT THAT WAS AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION MA'AM AND I
GUESS. LET ME JUST ASK IT IN A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WAY YOU ALL
HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING I GUESS
WITH THIS. EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT AND HOW MANY HOURS
I THINK THERE WAS A STUDY THAT
WAS DONE A FEW YEARS AGO. SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEED TO PUT
IT IN A BILL IF WE'RE GOING TO
CHANGE THE NUMBER OF HOURS SAID
BERBERS IN BURR RIDGE TO BE IN
COSMETOLOGIST TO BE THE DEBATE
IN ORDER TO SECURE LICENSURE
HOW LONG IS IT GOING TO TAKE
YOU AND YOUR BOARD TO FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY HOW MANY HOURS NEED
TO BE IN THE CURRICULUM FOR A
BARBER OR COSMETOLOGIST OR ANY
OF THE CATEGORIES THAT FIT IN
THERE- IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. WAIT I THINK IT. SINCE
I'VE BEEN WITH THE BOARD THERE
ARE MAYBE ONE RIGHT BEFORE I
BECAME TO THE BOARD THEY
REVIEWED THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
OUR CURRICULUM AND THEN. AS YOU
MENTIONED I'M JUST A FEW YEARS
BACK. AND BOTH TIMES THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO MAINTAIN
THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS- I
THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IT IN
A DIFFERENT WAY I NEED- THAT
THE TIMES HAVE CHANGED I THINK
THIS IS. A NATIONAL DISCUSSION
THAT'S HAPPENED I PERSONALLY
HAD HAD NUMEROUS DISCUSSIONS ON
THE NATIONAL LEVEL. THAT THIS
IS- SOMETHING THAT THAT NEEDS
TO BE LOOKED AT IN A WAY. M.
NOT SO MUCH OF HOW WE CAN
REDUCE BUT WHAT WHAT SHOULD THE
HOURS BEFORE A COSMETOLOGIST SO
I THINK. THE BOARD THAT M.
MICHAEL MY CURRENT BOARD AND I
THINK IS VERY OPEN TO THIS I
THINK IT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT- WE SEE THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE A DIFFERENT LOOK AT THIS
AND TRYING TO DO. NOT JUST
MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO JUST
FOR THE SAKE OF. MAINTAINING
THE STATUS QUO BUT REALLY LOOK
AT. THE RISKS INVOLVED IN THE
IN THE SERVICES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICES. AND DETERMINE WHAT
TYPE OF HEALTH AND SAFETY M.
AND WHAT TYPE OF RISKY GOES TO
THE CONSUMER AND THAT SHE NEEDS
TO BE OUR FOCUS FOR DEVELOPING
CURRICULUM. WILL SINCE YOU WILL
HAVE DONE THIS A FEW TIMES AND
SINCE YOU'VE BEEN THERE FOR. A
FEW YEARS- DO YOU THINK THIS
ROUTE THIS REVIEW THIS INTERNAL
REVIEW BY YOU AND YOUR BOARD.
CAN BE COMPLETED IN A YEAR.
ABSOLUTELY OKAY BECAUSE THAT'LL
BE VERY HELPFUL TO US IN
DECIDING WHAT WE DO. IN THESE
COMMITTEES WITH RESPECT TO
SUNSET REVIEW SO THE- REVIEW OF
THE- CURRICULUM THE CURRICULA-
FOR THESE VARIOUS THESE
OCCUPATIONS- COULD BE COMPLETED
WITHIN CERTAINLY WITHIN A
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD AND WE CAN
HAVE A DETERMINATION AS TO WHAT
THE- WHAT THE NEW IF THERE IS A
NEW- EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENT IS
FOR BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
DEFINITELY AGREE OKAY PERFECT-
AND I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
SENATOR RITUAL BOOK FOR ASKING
THAT QUESTION VERY VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION COLLEAGUES
ANY FURTHER. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS I SEE NINE FROM THE
FLOOR. LET'S NOW TURN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ANY
COMMENTS ABOUT THE BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
BEGINNING WITH WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AND THERE ARE NONE
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
WHO WISH TO PROVIDE COMMENTS.
AND BEFORE WE GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE I SEE CENTER BATES. HAVE
A QUESTION CENTER BATES I
APOLOGIZE FOR OVERLOOKED I
THINK. SORRY FINISHER OUTSIDE I
THINK MAYBE I DIDN'T HAVE MY
HAND HIGH ENOUGH ON THE SCREEN
THERE BETTER NOT DISCLOSED TO
ISSUE THAT WERE. ACTUALLY
COVERED IN THE MEDIA AND SAN
DIEGO ACTUALLY ARE IN BC NOT
OUR DISCUSSION REGARDING THE
ACT EXAMINE AND LICENSING
BACKLOG THAT. THE TOWNS- YEAH
IT BASS STALLING. ABILITY B.
HOPEFULLY THE- EXAMINE PEOPLE
WHO PASS OR EXAMINE THE ARGUED
NEITHER LICENSE SIDE TO
ACTUALLY WORK UNDER A LICENSEE
ARE SO THAT THEY CAN CAPITAL
SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS SIGNED
ME ON. AND ON AND THERE'S NOT A
HUMAN CRYING NOW THERE ARE
PROJECTIONS BEING ON HOLD
BECAUSE THERE IS THIS BACKLOG
AND I'M HOPING WE ARE HAVE A
PROCESS OR WE ARE. ADDING MORE
ON. RESOURCES SO THAT YOU CAN
TAKE CARE THAT MAC LOG SO THEY
CAN'T GET UP AND RUNNING.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE KOBE AD-
CERTAINLY PUT THAT A LOT OF
THAT ON HOLD ONE OF OUR
CONGRESSMAN FROM SOUTH EASTERN
SAN DIEGO HOUSE ASKING OTHER
DIRECTLY IF THERE COULD BE A
WAIVER PROCESS. MAYBE THE
QUESTION IS ONE HOW ARE YOU
DOING WITH THE BACKLOG WHAT
RESOURCES HAVE YOU ADDED ON TO
ARE YOU AWARE. THAT THERE HAS
BEEN A REQUEST DIRECTLY TO THE
GOVERNOR IT COULD BE A WAIVER
PROCESS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS.
COULD START WORKING ON YOUR
LICENSEE. THANK YOU FOR
QUESTION. I AM YES WE HAVE BUT
I'M VERY HARD TO. OUR BACKLOG
OF OUR EXAMS. AND YOU KNOW WORK
WITH THE KILTED PANDEMIC WE DID
HAVE TO CLOSE DOWN OUR
EXAMINATION SITE. AND I WILL
TELL YOU AND JUST JUST FOR
AWARENESS MYSELF AND MISTER
WEEKS NEXT NEAR BOTH FULLY
VACCINATED WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
SITTING NEXT TO EACH OTHER WITH
NO MASK. I AM BUT OUR OUR EXAM
SITES HAVE HAVE BEEN HIT VERY
HARD BECAUSE WE DID HAVE TO
CLOSE. AND FOR OUR PRACTICAL
EXAM IT'S BASICALLY SET UP LIKE
A THE LINE IN A SENSE THERE'S
EIGHT STATIONS IN THIS
FACILITY. I AM IN MULTIPLE
ROOMS WHERE ONE OF OUR STAFF
ACTUALLY EXAMINES AND OBSERVES
THE OPERATIONS THAT. EACH AB DE
CANDIDATES. SO AND ONE IN IN.
TIMES THROUGHOUT THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC WE EITHER HAD
TO CLOSE OUR SITE COMPLETELY.
AND WHEN WE HAVE BEEN OPEN
WE'VE HAD TO THE OPEN AT 50%
CAPACITY. AND TODAY WERE OPEN
AT 50% CAPACITY BUT WE ARE
LOOKING TO YOU OPEN BACK TO
FULL CAPACITY AND IN LATE JUNE
EARLY JULY. BUT I WILL TELL YOU
THAT WE HAVE ADDRESSED THE
BACKLOG EVERYONE THAT HAS BEEN
WAY EVERYBODY. UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAD TO CANCEL MANY PEOPLE'S
EXAMINATIONS- AND SO WE DID
AND- WE HAVE SCHEDULED EVERYONE
NOW. WE SCHEDULED AND EVERY
EVERY PERSON AND IT WAS UP TO.
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND CANDIDATES
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET AT
LEAST AN EXAM DATE SO THEY KNOW%
THEY'RE THEY'RE WHERE THEY ARE
AT THIS POINT- AND LUCKILY AND
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE NO MORE AND-
SITUATIONS THAT MANY OUTBREAKS
OR ANY SEARCHES SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE WITH OUR BUSINESS. AND
WE ARE WE'VE ADDED ADDITIONAL
STAFF THEM AND WE ARE ADDING
MORE JUST MORE STAFF TO TRY TO
INCREASE. OUR CAPACITY EVEN
EVEN IF WE REMAIN AT HALF
CAPACITY BUT WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING TO ADD ADDITIONAL
SESSIONS TO HELP PEOPLE GET
THAT TEST. M. THE SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER I AM AND I AM AWARE
OF THE AND THE CONGRESSMEN'S.
LETTER BUT THERE HAVE I AM I
HAVEN'T HAD ANY DISCUSSIONS ON
ANY TYPE OF WAIVER. AND TO
WAIVE EXAMINATIONS TO GET
PEOPLE AND INTO THE INDUSTRY
QUICKER BUT FROM OUR STANDPOINT
WE WE'VE DONE IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS WE'VE PROBABLY PROCESS
FOR WORK THAN THAN WE EVER
HAVE. IN GETTING INFORMATION TO
THOSE CANDIDATES- WHO HAVE.
BEEN AND SO IT'S BEEN VERY
UNFORTUNATE THAT THEY'VE HAD
THEIR HAVE THEIR EXAM SCHEDULE
BUT THEY DO. ALL HAVE A DATE
NOW AT THIS TIME. DO I
UNDERSTAND IT CREEK AFTER PASS
YOUR EXAM THE YOU HAVE.
DISTINCT HER HOURS OR STAFF PRE
EXAM AS AN INTERN FOR EXAMPLE
ORDERS THAT POST EXAM YOU NEED
TO SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS BEFORE
YOU ACTUALLY GET YOUR LICENSE.
IT SPREE SO YOU YOU IT CAN'T BE
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS FOR A
COSMETOLOGY LICENSE AND THEN
YOU COME TO US FOR THE- M. WE
DO THE EXAMINATION OF WITH A
PORTION THAT CONSIDERED ARE
WRITTEN IN THE WE HAVE A
PORTION THAT THE HANDS ON EXAM.
AND ONCE HE PASSED BOTH THOSE
BOTH THOSE QUESTIONS YOU'RE
HANDED AT LICENSE RIGHT THERE
AT OUR EXAM SITE- SO THERE'S
NOT A LAG BETWEEN PASSING THE
EXAM AND THEN GETTING YOUR
LICENSE SO YOU CAN GO RIGHT
INTO OUR- PRACTICING. CORRECT
WELL THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU FOR
ANY ANSWERS TO THAT AND
HOPEFULLY THAT COMMUNICATES TO
OUR- OUR OUR CONGRESSMEN ON
WHO'S UP. I UNDERSTAND ANSEL
YES THE LEGAL MENTION NAMES
THAT HE KNOWS ARE OF. WHOM I
SPEAK SO THANK. I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU SO BATES. MEMBERS ANY
OTHER COMMENTS CONCERNS I SEE
NONE IN THE ROOM AND I NO
RAISED ON THE SCREEN FOR THE
FROM THOSE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. ROOM ONE TWELVE THERE
NO WITNESSES THERE THAT'S MOVED
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING OF THIS
MODERATOR FEW PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH WITNESSES. AND WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU COULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND HAVE
NOT ALREADY DONE SO ME PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. PHOTO
FOR STREAMLINED THIRTEEN ONE
THREE CAROLINA THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS WENDY
COCHRAN AND ON THE CALIFORNIA
LICENSE APPLICATION FOUNDER OF
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION
APPLICATION ADVOCACY AND
CALIFORNIA STATIC ALLIANCE I
REPRESENTS OVER NINETY THOUSAND
LICENSED CALIFORNIA SITUATIONS
THE LARGEST PROPHETIC MARKETS
IN THE COUNTRY. SOME OF YOUR
HEARING TODAY HAD CAREERS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. I'M
ASKING YOU TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECALL AND COMPARE WHAT YOU
WERE DOING THAT AND HOW YOUR
PROFESSION IS INVOLVED BECAUSE
OF INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE BEING LOCKLEY
CONSTRAINS TO WORKING WITH THE
ROLODEX A TYPEWRITER AND IT'S
JUST NOT THAT THERE'S NO PAT
AND THE TOOLS OF YOUR TRADE NOW
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
CALIFORNIA LICENSE APPLICATIONS
NOT HOW TO RESELL ABBREVIATION
IT'S GOT THE PRACTICES NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. FORTY THREE
YEARS AGO WHEN THE LICENSE OF
THE REGIONAL CREATED. ONE SIDE
WITH NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THE
DISTRICT OUT HERE IN NAIL CARE
SERVICES AND CREATED A NEW
CLASSIFICATION OF LIFE
COMPETING PROFESSIONAL. AS THE
YEARS PROGRESSED NEVER HAD
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE REVIEWED
HOW ARE INDUSTRIES CHANGE ANY
POLITICALLY TO POLICY THE
KEEPING UP WITH THE INDUSTRY
TRENDS THE RESULT. COMMANDEER
THE SERVICES BEING STATEMENT
PERFORMED ACROSS THE COUNTRY BY
INSTITUTIONS ARE ACTUALLY
ILLEGAL. FOR US TO PERFORM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. PLEASE ALLOW THE
TO READ AND DETERMINE SERVICES
CAN SAFELY BE PROVIDE BY THEIR
LICENSEES BASED ON INDUSTRY
BEST PRACTICES AND CONSUMER
SAFETY. PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY
THE BBC IS CONSUMER SAFETY.
UPDATED STATUTORY LANGUAGE THE
BURDEN F KEEPING UP WITH
CONSUMER TRENDS CAN BE SHIFTED
TO A MORE NIMBLE ET SHE
ALLOWING THEM TO BUILD AND
MODIFY THE REGULATIONS AROUND
WHAT THEY CAN'T ENFORCE. WE
ALSO ARE AKING FOR A TRANSFER
OF PRIMARY OVERSIGHT AND THE
BEAUTY SCHOOLS OVER TO THE BBC.
PRIVATE MEETINGS FOR SPEND MORE
TIME TEACHING THEIR STUDENTS
HOW TO RUN SOCIAL MEDIA
CAMPAIGNS THAN THEY DO TEACHING
THEIR STUDENTS THE REGULATIONS
THAT GOVERN THEIR PROFESSIONAL
LICENSES. UNDER THE GUIDANCE OF
THE TPP UNDER QUALIFIED OFTEN
UNLICENSED AND NEWLY LICENSED
INSTRUCTORS ARE LEADING
STUDENTS. INCIDENTS OF STUDENTS
BEING TAUGHT OUT OF STILL
PRACTICES FOR HOW TO USE
LOOPHOLES AND GREY AREAS IS NOT
UNCOMMON. DISTRACTED SET UP
STUDENTS FOR POTENTIALLY COSTLY
FINES PENALTIES AGAINST THEIR
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE AND
CONSUMER HARM. EVEN HE LEADING
THE SCHOOL THESE PRACTICES CAN
BE STOPPED AND UNDERSTANDING OF
THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
REGULATIONS CAN'T BE EMPHASIZED
NOT MINUTE. DELETED AND
CIRCUMVENTED. EARLIER GENERAL
ROCK. AT CERTIFICATION HAVE
MEETING. YEAH DOES NOT REQUIRE
BABY HE CONTINUED EDUCATION AND
IT SHOULD NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
KNOWLEDGE ADVANCED
CERTIFICATION TO DEMONSTRATE
COMPETENCY SAFETY AND
PROFESSIONAL ADVANCEMENT OF THE
UNIVERSE BEAUTY PROFESSIONAL
LICENSING. SENATOR BATES ALSO
NOTED THAT WE HAVE A BACKLOG OF
GRADUATES THAT IT WAITED ALMOST
TWO YEARS TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
THEIR LICENSING EXAM. WE WOULD
ASK THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME
SORT OF ASSISTANCE. IF THE
SPENDING THE PRACTICAL
EXAMINATION UNDER AN EMERGENCY
ORDER IN ORDER FOR THOSE PEOPLE
TO PASS THEIR EXAMINATIONS INTO
WRITTEN FORMAT AND MOVE ON TO.
THE COMING THE LICENSE KEYS
THAT WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE
COMPETENTLY TRAINED IN THE
SCHOOL OF. CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL
LIFE ALSO SUPPORTS EIGHTY TWO
THIRTY ONE WE BELIEVE IN EQUAL
TREATMENT OF ALL LICENSE PLATE
UNDER THE BBC. SUPPORTING
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY ONE. FROM WIN
WILL ALLOW LICENSE MANAGER THE
OPTION TO DO FRENCH ACCORDING
TO EIGHTY FIVE MANAGERS HVE
BEEN SINGLED OUT I WILL DO THIS
EXEMPTION WITHOUT YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND TIME. OUR
WORK IS WORKING WITH YOU OFF
THE CHANGE. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. HELLO LINE FIFTEEN ONE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU SENATOR ROB ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW AND MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FRED JONES
AND FOR THE LAST TWENTY ONE
YEARS I HAVE. GIVEN VOICE TO
THE BEAUTY AND BARBERING
INDUSTRY AS A REGISTERED
LOBBYIST AND LEGAL COUNSEL FOR
THE PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA. I WANT
TO COMMEND STAFF FOR THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE BACKGROUND
REPORT- WE DO HAVE SOME%
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES- THE
STAFF THE STAFF RECOMMENDED IN
TERMS OF ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
BARRIERS OF ENTRY CONCERN THAT
HAS BEEN PLACED BY SEVERAL-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS INCLUDING NEW
CHAIRMAN LAW- I. LIKE TO NOTE
THAT THERE ARE OVER SIX HUNDRED
SIXTEEN THOUSAND ACTIVE
LICENSEES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE LICENSED BY OUR STATE BOARD
OF BARBERING COSMETOLOGY
THAT'S- OVER 2% OF EVERY
CALIFORNIA ADULT. SO WHATEVER
CLEAR YOU'RE SAYING A. B. THEY
HAVEN'T HAMPERED QUITE A BIT OF
PEOPLE FROM GETTING THIS
LICENSE WE ALSO HAVE AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THAT WAS
BRIEFLY TOUCHED UPON. AFTER
JUST THIRTY NINE HOURS OF
FORMAL INSTRUCTION THESE
APPRENTICES ARE ALLOWED TO GO
TO WORK. AND EARN WHILE THEY
LEARN IN A BARBER SHOP OR SALON
SETTING. SO THERE ARE OTHER
MEANS OF ENTRY INTO THIS
INDUSTRY OTHER THAN JUST THE
FORMAL EDUCATION ROUTE. HOWEVER
THE VAST VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
LICENSE USE CHOSE THE FORMAL
EDUCATION ROUTE FOR A LOT OF
VERY GOOD REASONS OUR LOW
APPRENTICESHIP LICENSING EXAM
PASS RATE IS JUST ONE OF MANY.
THAT SHOW THAT GOING THROUGH
FORMAL EDUCATION SETTING
PROVIDES A MUCH BETTER
FOUNDATION- FOR MOST OF OUR
LICENSEES. WE WOULD LIKE TO.
AND REENTER WHAT MISTER WEEKS
SAID. CURRENTLY THE COSMETOLOGY
LICENSE IS KIND OF THE OVER
ARCHING MASTER LICENSE WHICH
INCLUDES ALL THREE AREAS HAIR
SKIN NAILS. HOWEVER THE STATE
BOARD ONLY HAS SUBLICENSE THIS
FOR SKIN AND NAILS WHICH ARE
CONSIDERABLY LESS HOURS OF
COURSE IN COSMETOLOGY. WE
BELIEVE THE BOARD SHOULD CREATE
A SUBLICENSE FOR THOSE THAT
JUST WANT TO DO HAIR HAIRSTYLES
LICENSE AND WE THINK THAT COULD
BE CONSIDERABLY LESS HOURS THAN
THE CURRENT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS BECAUSE MENTALITY BUT WE
ALSO ARE SPONSORING LEGISLATION
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
THIS YEAR. TO DRAMATICALLY
EXPAND THE EXTERNSHIP PROGRAM
TO ALLOW OUR STUDENTS TO GO TO
WORK IN A SALON SETTING SOONER
DURING YOUR EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE AND ACTUALLY
RECEIVED HEY FOR SUCH. A. ONE
ON THE JOB EXPERIENCE. WE ALSO
ARE- OPEN TO THE AND WOULD LIKE
TO. AS YOU CRAFT. HUGER ABLE
WINDING OF CLOCKTOWER CREDIT
AND COMPETENCY CERTIFICATION.
SO THAT MAYBE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND THEORETICAL
INSTRUCTION CAN HAVE MINIMUM
CLOCK HOURS ASSIGNED TO
STATUTORILY. THE SCHOOLS ARE
ABLE TO CERTIFY BE ON. HANDS ON
PRACTICAL COMPETENCIES BEYOND
THOSE MINIMUM CLOCKTOWER-
THEORETICAL INSTRUCTION. I WILL
ALSO SAY- IN RESPONSE TO SOME
MEMBERS CONCERNED ESPECIALLY
CHAIRMAN- LOS CONCERNED ABOUT
HEY. THIS IS AN ALL CASH
INDUSTRY AND UNFORTUNATELY
UNDER REPORTING INCOME IS
RAMPANT IT'S ALMOST. NOBODY IN
THEIR RIGHT MIND WOULD WORK FOR
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS AN HOUR
ESPECIALLY FOR A PHYSICALLY
RIGOROUS CAREER OF LIKE MANIC
JERRY AND BELIEVE ME NOBODY
DOES. THEY TOLD REPORTERS THERE
CASH SERVICE INCOME AND
ACCIDENT FORTUNATE BECAUSE IT
CREATES CONVERSATIONS WITH
POLICY MAKERS AND REGULATORS
LIKE WE'VE BEEN HAVING TODAY. I
WILL ALSO SAY IN THOSE STATES
THAT HAVE LASSEN SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS. THEY ALSO HAVE A
MUCH MORE FAVORABLE THE
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYEES- CLIENT AND
SO THEY HAVE MORE EMPLOYER
BASED SALONS. CALIFORNIA WELL
OVER THREE QUARTERS OF OUR
SALONS HAVE MOVED AWAY FROM THE
EMPLOYER RELATIONSHIP INTO
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
RELATIONSHIP. OR WHAT WE CALL
TO THE CORRECT. AND THOSE
RENTAL ESTá OWNERS ARE NOT. TO
ADD TO IT WITH ANY TYPE OF
TRAINING THANK NOT REQUIRED CAN
YOU PROVIDE IT WHEREAS IN THE
STATES HAVE MORE FAVOR EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIPS LABOR
LAWS. DO PROVIDE AND AUGMENTS
THEIR EDUCATION WHEN THEY COME
OUT OF SCHOOLS WITH LESS HOURS
WE ARE CONCERNED IF YOU CUT
BACK HOURS ARBITRARILY. AND IF
YOU DO WAY WITH THE PRACTICAL
EXAM AS A STAFF REPORT
RECOMMENDS. YOU WILL BE
PROVIDED LICENSES TO PEOPLE
THAT DO NOT HAVE THE PRACTICAL
HANDS ON COMPETENCIES THIS IS A
VERY TACTILE TEXTURES INDUSTRY.
EVERYTHING THAT A STUDENT DOES
IN A SCHOOL SETTING WHETHER
IT'S IN FRONT OF A COMPUTER
LEARNING LEARNING THEORY. OR
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES FOR
ACTUALLY DOING SERVICES WITH
THEIR HANDS EVERYTHING THEY'RE
DOING IS HEALTH AND SAFETY
PASSED THE POINT OF SCHOOL
SERVES TO CHEAPEN HOUSING
REALISTICALLY. OPERATE YES- I'M
A VERY TALL AFTER I'M A VERY
TALLER SUGAR. THE MOST TOLERANT
IN THE ENTIRE. LEGISLATURE AND
YOU ARE TESTING MY ABILITY TO
BE TOLERANT HERE IN PUBLIC
COMMENT SO I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO CONSIDER ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS AND IN AS MUCH DETAIL
AS YOU WISH TO PROVIDE IN
WRITING. TO OUR COMMITTEE CHIEF
CONSULTANTS I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU MAKE ANY WRAP UP COMMENTS
THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO ABRUPTLY CUT YOU
OFF BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MOVE ON IN CASE THERE. ARE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
BEHIND YOU. WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
COMMENT BEFORE THE VICTIMS FROM
THIS ROOM OKAY. ABSOLUTELY
MISTER CHAIRMAN'S FORGIVE ME
FOR RATTLING OFF IDEA TO
PROVIDE JUSTICE MORNING IN
WRITING A LETTER TO SARAH MASON
ANDREW BOBBY SOME EXCEL BOTH
CONSULTANTS HAVE OUR LETTER ON
FILE AS OF THIS MORNING SO I
WILL WRAP UP WITH JUST ONE
OTHER ISSUE. WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONSIDER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LORENA GONZALEZ WE CLASS. THAT
STOLE OVERSIGHT OF OUR B. TWO
COLLEGES BE TRANSFERRED FROM
DPP TO OUR STATE BOARD THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
PLEASE. IN OUR NEXT LINE- COMMA
COMES FROM TEN ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS LAURA AND
OPEN AND I AM THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS DIRECTOR
FOR ASSOCIATED SKIN CARE
PROFESSIONALS ASSOCIATED HERE
PROFESSIONALS ASSOCIATED NOW
PROFESSIONALS. WE HAVE ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA- I DID TO MAKE
COMMENT YESTERDAY AND I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS HAVING YOU
ALL HAVING A HEARING ON THIS
TODAY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF G.
NINE THE FORD BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY IN CALIFORNIA- ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE BROUGHT
UP IN OUR LETTER IS. THAT BOARD
COMPOSITION AND WE WOULD ASK A
BAD LIGHT. OOPS IT ROTATED FOR
THE PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD. SO THAT PERHAPS AN
INSTITUTION OR MANAGERS COULD
BE ON AND THEN ROTATE THEM OUT
OR THE LICENSING GROUP THAT'S
IN OUR LETTER. ALSO WE ARE NAY
IF YOU DECIDE THAT SKIN CARE
SIDE WE WOULD ASK YOU
COMMITTEE OR A BAD- BOARD. TO
CONSIDER EXPANDING THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FOR EDUCATION. AND
THERE ARE. ACTIVE AS WINDY
SAYING OUR- ALLOWED TO BE
PERFORMED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY OR EVEN TOOLS THAT ARE
ALLOWED TO BE PURCHASED AT LIKE
A TARGET. BUT THE EDUCATION
THING CALIFORNIA COULD NOT DO
THOSE. CERVANTES CHAU WE ASKED
FOR THIS CODE- OF PRACTICE TO
BE REVISITED. AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT GIVING MORE AUTHORITY
TO THE SCHOOLS- FOR OVERNIGHT
AT THE SCHOOLS TO THE BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY AND
WE SUPPORT IT ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THIRTY ONE ON BEHALF OF OUR
NAIL PROFESSIONALS ARE
MANICURIST TO ALLOW THEM TO DO
THE CURRENT- WHO'S GRANT.
ORANGE WHAT EIGHTY FIVE AND
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION YOUR TIME TODAY
WE APPRECIATE YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NINE FOURTEEN DID
YOU HAVE A COMMENT TODAY LINE
WILL ONE FOR. NEXT PLEASE THANK
MISTER YEP THE THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU HAVING HEARD ALL THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY MEMBERS
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BOARD OF BARBERING.
AND COSMETOLOGY- YOU SEE NONE
SO I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEES IN
PARTICULAR CHAIR LOW. FOR HIS
COOPERATION IS INSIGHTFUL
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ALSO
THANK OUR WITNESSES FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY TODAY IN THE
COMMITTEES STAFFS THAT PUT THIS
TOGETHER. THANKS TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC FOR COMMENTING ON
THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE. SERVICE PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
OR THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. THANKS TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION CHAIR LOW IT
APPEARS THAT WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. SO WITH YOUR
PERMISSION THE JOINT SUNSET
REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARING WILL
BE ADJOURNED.